bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
cast probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille laura green cofondatrice et
secrétaire général de l'association
altruisme efficace france bonjour
l'europe
bonjour les ça va bien pas trop stressé
donc lors à ce que tu peux nous
présenter un peu ton ton parcours un peu
à la fois professionnel et un peu
philosophique on va dire ouais donc moi
j'ai un parcours plutôt généraliste j'ai
fait sciences po et j'ai fait sciences
po sur le campus de poitiers qu'un
campus qui est focalisée sur l'amérique
latine
donc voilà donc j'ai appris plein de
choses super intéressantes pendant
pendant ma licence sur plein de thèmes
différentes mais différent mais rien de
très très spécialisés et puis au fur et
à mesure je me suis un peu de plus en
plus intéressés à l'économie et
notamment d'ailleurs pour pour des
raisons de tes devoirs plus tard mais
lié à l'altruisme efficace de ce que ce
que je pensais pouvoir être utile dans
le monde d'avoir des compétences
peut-être un peu plus technique que que
ce que j'avais avec moi et mon parcours
très général voilà et donc j'ai fait
j'ai fait une une échange au brésil sur
dans une dans une faculté d'économie et
puis j'ai fait un master d'économie à
sciences po
pendant pendant les deux dernières
années et là je viens de finir mon
master et je bosse pour pour
l'association à plein temps donc tu
disais que j'étais secrétaire général je
ne suis plus secrétaire général
j'ai dû alors j'ai démissionné du
conseil d'administration et maintenant
je suis directrice exécutive de
l'association souhaite donc ça c'est
récente du coup c'est arrivé quand alors
ça c'est depuis novembre dernier et donc
je sais pas pourquoi l'amérique latine
dans une préférence particulière
ouais donc à l'époque c'était pas du
tout pour le coup des considérations sur
l'impact s'était juste ce qui
m'intéressait j'ai toujours beaucoup
aimé les langues et j'ai fait de
l'espagnol depuis la 6e et je voulais
apprendre du portugais et voilà je
trouvais jeu j'étais intéressé par par
la culture de plusieurs plusieurs pays
d'amérique latine et je voulais en
apprendre plus et du coup au brésil que
rester comme un ton qui restait un an
c'est juste une année des changes dans
le cadre de ma licence bon voila j'ai pu
à la fois beau c'est à la fois voyagé à
la fois à la fois étudier là bas et
c'était c'était vraiment très chouette
et du kobo paraît un peu plus attristées
fiasco man tu étais intéressé à la très
efficace comme sérieux alors je me suis
justement intéressé à l'altruisme
efficace quand j'étais au brésil
j'ai dès que j'ai je suis tombé sur une
vidéo sur un thème toque de peter singer
que d'ailleurs je recommande pour pour
ceux qui connaissent pas du tout
l'altruisme efficace et veulent une
première introduction et en fait j'ai
trouvé ça très proche d'idées que
j'avais déjà gtc il répondait à pas mal
des questions que je me posais déjà et
il l'est les thèmes dont il parlait au
coquet laquelle j'allais pas à pas
réfléchi je me suis dit ah nan mais
c'est fou il a trop raison c'est
exactement c'est exactement des idées
importantes a adressé dans le monde
voilà donc son son
pendant pendant son toque il il explique
un petit peu les fondements de cette
philosophie là un peu un peu sur une
idée de si on si on voit quelqu'un qui
est en qui en danger dans le monde
devant nous si on voit par exemple il a
un exemple une expérience de pensée
connu qui est sur l'enfant qui c'est
noir dont il ya peut-être par les toits
ou ou thibault dans tes vidéos france
que tu peux en parler maintenant
c'est donc valide l'idée c'est si si on
se balade dans la rue on ça marche pas
trop avec avec l'exemple de l'enfant qui
se noie on va dire peut-être on se
balade dans la forêt et on voit un gamin
qui est en train de se noyer dans une
dans un étang l'idée c'est qu'elle soit
en quelles sont nos intuitions par
rapport à ça est ce qu'on pense qu'il
faut aller aider l'enfant ou est ce que
est ce que est ce qu'on est ce qu'on se
dit que bon bah je sais pas si je suis
en retard au travail je peux être pas à
les sauver l'enfant
si j'ai un costume très cher je ne t'ai
pas à les sauver l'enfant si j'ai mon
iphone dans ma poche je ne t'ai pas
sauvé l'enfant est en fait on se rend
compte que la plupart des gens ont des
intuitions très forte qu'eux mêmes même
dans ces cas là il faut il faut aller
sauver l'enfant que ce serait monstrueux
de de l'effet de laisser l'enfant se
noyait juste au coût de 20 au prix de
son de son costard ou de sons de son
iphone et l'idée un petit peu de peter
singer c'est de dire bon bah si c'est
vrai dans ce cas là est-ce que c'est pas
vrai dans d'autres cas aussi est-ce
qu'on peut pas se poser la question de
si on a la possibilité de
métaphoriquement sauver un enfant qui se
noie qui en fait un enfant qui meurt de
malaria dans de paludisme dans un autre
pays où un enfant qui a je ne sais quel
maladie ou soucis dans un autre dans un
autre pays et d'ailleurs même si c'est
pas un enfant et d'ailleurs même si
c'est pas quelqu'un d'aujourd'hui mais
si c'est quelqu'un quelqu'un un enfant
qui n'est pas encore né keane être
l'année prochaine ou dans un an si on a
la possibilité de faire quelque chose
est-ce qu on n'a pas les même intuition
quoi est ce que est ce qu'on n'a pas
aussi envie de faire quelque chose de
même au prix de son joli costard ou de
son iphone
du coup c'est plus le côté altruisme
kita ouais ouais moi moi à la base c'est
vrai qu'il ya les gens les gens
s'intéressent à l'altruisme efficace de
plein de manières différentes
il ya pas mal de personnes qui savent
qu'ils s'y intéressent pour plutôt pour
le côté intellectuel qui commence à se
poser des questions philosophiques moral
et puis qui arrive un peu
inéluctablement à la conclusion que il
faut aider les autres et puis que que
c'est bien de faire du bien dans le
monde tout ça et puis il ya d'autres ya
d'autres personnes comme moi qui qui
commence avec bon cette intuition très
forte que bien sûr il faut aider les
autres bien sûr on pourrait passer une
partie de notre notre vie à aider les
autres et puis et puis qui après se pose
la question de comment le faire au mieux
qua non que moi à titre personnel c'est
un peu l'inversé c'est plus le côté
efficace qui y qui m'a intéressé au
début et puis après en déroulant un peu
le raisonnement c'est donc d'un an avec
ses arguments c'est l'expérience de
pensée des peter singer
ça fait réfléchir du coup quelques et
comment il voit la terre et à réflexion
petit à petit avec la très efficace que
je suis imagine que tu as fait pas mal
de chemin depuis sept premiers points
visage de tijd
ouais donc voilà donc à donc allé à
l'époque où tout bouge et où j'ai vu
stento que j'ai tout de suite en fait
ils parlaient de pas mal d'organisation
et de et de sites web différents dont
kim et il m'a dirigé le septeto que mam
a redirigé vers le site web de giving
what we can qui est une organisation qui
fait partie qui se revendique un peu de
ces principes là de l'altruisme efficace
et qui qui essaie d'encourager les gens
à donner un pourcentage de leurs revenus
a donné 10 % de leurs revenus au cours
de leur vie pour des causes en haut un
pacte et vert 80 miller qui est une
organisation aussi
qui fait partie de la même sphère et qui
là se penche plutôt sur les sur les
carrières des gens sur qu'est ce que les
gens peuvent faire avec leur temps avec
le pommeau pendant leur carrière pour
aider les autres d'une manière qui est
vraiment donc donc suite à athènes tôt
que je veux aller un petit peu exploré
les sites web dont il parlait à travers
80 mille heures j'ai commencé à me poser
des questions sur mon propre parcours
sur ma propre carrière sur sûre qu'est
ce que je pouvais faire pour avoir plus
d'impact que que qu'avec la voie où je
m'étais je m'étais lancé un peu et
et voilà donc ça m'a aidé un peu à
trouver cette idée de faire un master en
économie
et puis j'ai tout de suite fait tout de
suite j'ai rapidement signer le pledge
donc je sais pas comment on peut dire ça
en français le la promesse de don la
première l'engagement de giving what we
can a donné 10 % de mon revenu au cours
de ma vie actif donc ça c'était un peu
la première étape un peu plus diriger
vers l'action et puis après la réflexion
là dessus elle elle a plutôt commencé à
évoluer à se développer à devenir un
petit peu moins un peu moins cru en
rencontrant des gens
gg je suis allé au à une conférence à
oxford à l'université d'oxford en 2015
ce qui s'appelle i et globale donc
factors and the bow la conférence
mondiale de la trousse médicale et et
lors de cette conférence en fait j'ai
appris des trucs via les toc des
différents des différentes personnes qui
étaient là mais surtout en parlant à
plein de gens qui sont intéressés par
ces idées là qui ont des parcours super
différents et qui m'ont appris plein de
choses sur sur dd des sphères vraiment
super spécifique quoi y'a des ya des
experts en plein de choses qui parlait
avec beaucoup de passion de leurs
de leurs deux de leurs intérêts de leurs
de leur expertise
j'ai vu que tu disais qu'avec
probablement tu essayes d'interviewer un
peu des gens qui ont qui ont d'autres
expertises que toi ou thibault parce que
tu trouve ça très intéressant moi
c'était un peu ça j'avais un parcours
hyper généraliste est hyper curieuse de
tout mais mais mais je n'avais pas
forcément des expertises dans quoi que
ce soit et de parler là avec des gens
qui étaient ben ouais biologiste qui qui
qui travaillaient sur sur le le le
vieillissement qui rêve qui voyait s'il
y avait une possibilité de retrouver une
arme aide au vieillissement c'était des
choses qui étaient complètement
hallucinante et ça c'est vraiment c'est
leur boulot quoi c'est des gens qui
bossent vraiment là-dessus ça existe
quoi et des gens qui qui qui bosse à
google pour google dit mind est qui et
qui bossent sur sur l'intelligence
artificielle des gens qui sont des
dirigeants de petites ong qui essayent
de dette de vraiment être transparents
et regarder leurs actions de façon
minutieuse tout ça c'était c'était
vraiment trop intéressé en fait de juste
parler à des gens des experts dans leurs
champs et d'avoir du temps pour leur
parler
là ça va vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
pays veulent évoluer ma réflexion et du
coup on compte quand tout est décidé à
aller y est globale c'était quand tu
étais au au brésil on pourrait donc gt
gt au brésil en 2014 donc à l'année
scolaire 2014 2015
il n'y a pas très longtemps et commence
à pas trop comme et est donc j'ai
découvert le l'altruisme efficace en fin
d'année on décembre 2014 quelque chose
comme ça et puis et puis à mon retour en
france
en ce sens je crois que tu en août ou en
septembre il y avait cette conférence là
et je me suis inscrite et voilà j'ai été
accepté à cette conférence a été très
très contente ok et d'écouté étudié
parti tout seul aussi un peu à
l'aventuré n'était pas de cet acier de
feintes à parler un peu de la tribu
efficace autour de toi à ce moment là je
peux les autres gens qui t'intéresse pas
alors pas tellement je pense que j'en ai
parlé un peu autour de moi mes amis et
tout ça on regarde c'est génial c'est
les questions que je me posais il ya en
fait il ya des réponses il ya des gens
qui se pose exactement les mêmes les
mêmes réponses et qui voit les mêmes
questions et qui ont qui ont parfois des
réponses ou des débuts de réponse et
notamment notamment j'avais un ami avec
avec lequel avant de découvrir cette
histoire d'altruisme efficace on s'était
déjà posé la question de l'efficacité
des différentes interventions et
différentes organisations caritatives et
on s'était dit c'est quand même
hallucinant il faudrait qu'on crée une
start up qui qui réfléchissent à
l'efficacité des dégâts à l'impact des
différentes des différentes
organisations j'ai pas cités dans ces
termes mais à quel point à quel point ça
ça marche comment es tu es et qu'on les
notes quoi qu'on leur donne des notes
mais qu'on se concentre pas juste sur
comment elles sont dirigées ou je ne
sais quoi qu on se concentre vraiment
sur sûr si on le l'impact qu'elles ont
sur leurs bénéficiaires au final donc
vous n'avez pas monter cette start up on
n'a pas monté cette start up parce qu'on
s'est lancé dit que j'en avais besoin
d'un peu plus de background que voilà
que avec j'attends d'un petit peu
d'avoir d'avoir fait d'aider d'avoir
fini les études tout ça et puis et puis
après j'ai découvert ça donc on s'est
dit ah bah zut ça existe déjà
on a raté notre idée de start up ce que
guide donc tu pensais qu'ils veulent ce
qu'ils veulent c'est si vieux que ça me
voici 2007
je crois assez assez assez peut-être à
vérifier cgg 2007 en tête avec quelques
années de retard
c'est cette espèce est donc il ya global
c'était à londres ces saoudiennes
s'étaient à c'était donc à oxford il y
en a
maintenant c'est sûr c'est souvent à
londres celui qui ce qui se passe au
royaume uni ça se passe à londres mais
il y en avait simultanément ou à peu
près en même temps dans le temps dans
l'est dans les quelques mois autour de
autour de août septembre il y en avait
il y en a aussi en australie j'ai testé
à melbourne ou sydney et puis on a aux
états unis souvent à san francisco
parfois à boston il ya plusieurs y ait
plusieurs de ses conférences ce don
selon la localisation du coup qu'est ce
qui se passe
il est globalement compris que tout
allait rencontrer des gens très très
très intéressant et très intéressé mais
quand ça se passe il ya des conflits les
présentations j'imagine
ouais il ya déjà des conférences sur
plein de sujets différents
maintenant ça devient un peu plus
restrictif n'aurait pas mal de gens qui
veulent venir à ces conférences donc
donc c'est un tout petit peu plus
difficile de diack cd il faut il faut
faire une demande de candidature tout ça
ce qui était ce qu'était ce qui était
mon moins difficile il ya quelques
années est en fait il ya déjà des
conférences un peu iggy pour différents
niveaux il ya déjà des hadjis exténué
gay indépendants qui se passe dans dans
plusieurs dans plusieurs villes du monde
peut-être mais là mais peut-être entre
entre 3 3 et 5 par an je dirais
peut-être peut-être même de moins que ça
parfois et ça c'est surtout ouvert aux
débutants aux personnes qui commencent à
découvrir l'altruisme efficace et qui
veulent des présentations d'introduction
sur pas mal de sujets et les gadgi donc
à londres san francisco et melbourne on
va dire
sont en général un peu plus avancée pour
les gens c'est pour ces pour rassembler
les personnes qui s'intéressent à ces
sujets là c'est s2 communauté mondiale
de la truffe efficace qui est souvent
parle de manière virtuelle s'échangent
des des articles des postes et des
arguments en ligne là c'est pour ces
pour les rassembler pour pour que les
gens qui ont des idées un petit peu
novatrice qui propose des nouvelles des
nouvelles nouveau problème des nouvelles
cause dans le mouvement altruisme
efficace l occasion de les présenter
quoi du coup il ya combien de personnes
dansent lors de conférence i o globo
je pense que c'est peut-être autour de
300 2 500 parfois je pense à paris ça
varie selon les années et les lieux
qu'ils arrivent à trouver et selon m
haies mais je sais c'est cet ordre
d'idée mais bien de jour que c'est sur
un week end
en général c'est entre le vendredi et le
dimanche voilà et c'est top cool ça
c'est un très chouette et donc c'est là
que tu as rencontré olivier g pas
rencontré olivier la barre j'ai
rencontré un autre ami qui s'appelle
thomas sittler qui avait avec avec
lesquels on a guetté qui était qui était
à sciences po aussi à l'époque et qui
était qui était aussi un jeune un
étudiant comme moi et qui qui venait de
commencer sa sa licence à oxford qui
était passé de sciences po à oxford et
puis il m'a dit qu'il avait commencé à
réfléchir à wawa créé je sais plus où
j'en étais mais a créé un petit groupe à
sciences po en petits groupes sur
l'altruisme efficace à sciences po
moi je me suis dit ah super il va
exister quelque chose en france moi
justement je rentre du brésil je me suis
dit mais je m'étais dit que c'était trop
nul de rentrer du brésil et là j'avais
de nouveau quelque chose qui
m'enthousiasmait
moment que j'étais vraiment contente de
faire donc voilà donc j'ai pu contribuer
au lancement de ce petit groupe de dasté
altruisme efficace sciences po c'est sa
lancée vous êtes devenu une association
rattachée la science po ouais ouais
c'était une association étudiante la
navette on a créé un petit groupe on est
et on était quatre ou cinq avec tom
briché vallier qui est toujours très
actif dans l'altruisme efficace puis
quelqu'un quelques autres aussi qui qui
sont plus ou moins actifs et du coup
quand vous êtes passé ensuite le truisme
efficacement son côté président porte et
dieu
on a commencé à se dire que sciences po
c'était c'était sympa mais y'avait pas
toujours beaucoup de monde qui venait à
nos événements notamment parce qu'il ya
plein d'associations étudiantes qu'il ya
plein de conférences super intéressante
avec différents différentes différents
intervenants super qui viennent
présenter des trucs donc au final la
commune et combien pas mal de boulot et
pas mal de d'événements différents tous
les soirs c'est un peu difficile de
sortir du lot c'est un peu difficile
quand c'est une nouvelle asso dont
personne n'a entendu parler d'avoir des
événements où on attire pas mal de gens
ou les gens s'intéressent à quelque
chose d'un peu nouveau
et on sait on s'est dit que quelque
chose qui pourrait être sympa ce serait
de créer des mythes up d'aider des
rencontres avec avec peu d'efforts pour
les préparer à paris ou où les gens
pourraient se rencontrer les parisiens
qui s'intéressent à l'altruisme
efficaces pourraient se rencontrer
on avait déjà une page facebook créée
crée donc par par un autre cofondateur
florent berthet qui qui a qui avait créé
une page facebook sur l'altruisme
efficace et donc on en a posté on a
commencé à poster sur 7 sur cette page
facebook en disant ah ben voilà
est ce que certains d'entre vous
seraient intéressés de se rencontrer de
façon informelle sur paris et au 1er mi
temps qu'on organisait avec avec thomas
encore olivier venu et puis guillaume
aussi guillaume voreux cliquer qui est
dans les premiers membres de de l'assaut
aient cessées voilà on a commencé à
réfléchir à oui mais est-ce que ce qui
aurait pas besoin d'une structure un
petit peu plus pérenne en france qui qui
permettent aux personnes qui sont
intéressées par ces idées de square
données de de réfléchir ensemble d'avoir
des idées de projets et donc les règles
avait décidé d'en certificat de france
veut on part on parle d'olivier depuis
tout à l'heure mais donc c'est olivier
bertrand pour ceux qui connaissent pas
et donc c'est l'actuel président parce
que ça change et ça suit pas et donc ça
c'est en 2015 encore 2016 c'était début
de semaine ça il me semble peut-être fin
2015 début 2016 hockey et du cou donc au
début l'humanité dumont télé les statuts
mais aujourd'hui mme parent qu'est ce
que vous avez commencé à faire petit à
petit qu'est ce que fait être une
efficace france
alors au début on s'est dit qu'on serait
vraiment une plateforme construit on
avait vraiment envie d'être un lieu
d'échangés c'était c'était pour ça qu'on
a qu'on a créé ça on voulait permettre à
des des groupes locaux inspiré de
l'altruisme efficace en france de ceux
de ce2 se monte et de se coordonner et
d'avoir des ressources grâce à nous de
pas à chaque fois à refaire le même
process de d'avoir des débuts du
matériel en france est déjà parce que le
le la truite efficace et c'est quand
même un mouvement anglophone à la base
donc on voulait on voulait permettre à
des gens qui s'intéressent à ces idées
en france d'avoir plus facilement
ddd des ressources peu pouvoir pointer
vers notre site sans refaire tout un
site de pouvoir
avoir des gens qui viennent faire des
présentations des gens d'altruisme
efficace france qui viennent faire des
présentations à différents endroits
enfin voilà d'agir comme une ressource
centrale est une plateforme de
coordination pour pour différentes
personnes en france qui ait ce qui était
intéressé par ça et donc là je parle
d'aider des groupes locaux donc des gens
dont l'intérêt est de promouvoir des
idées de l'altruisme efficace donc c'est
déjà un peu un peu mais tu as mais même
les gens plus à l'object mais veulent
qu'ils ont des idées de deux projets sur
comment aider les autres de pouvoir se
retrouver network et se changer aussi
être être challenge est sûre sur leurs
idées quand quelqu'un un super projet
une intervention qui lui paraît vraiment
super efficace de pouvoir avoir un
groupe de personnes virtuellement et en
personne à qui à qui s'adresser pour
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir réfléchir à
six est ce que c'est vraiment une bonne
idée est ce qu'il ya pas mieux qu'ils
pourraient faire voilà du coup de la
troisième efficace fonctionnant en
france c'est beaucoup sur des réseaux
sociaux ou des phrases comme ça en privé
un peu public par wave c'est un peu je
pense je pense qu'on essaye quand même
de deux d'avoir des événements et des
occasions pour les gens de se rencontrer
en personne et une partie qui est
virtuel mais je pense que c'est aussi
sympa hélas hélas ça revient petit peu
sur ce que christophe disait dans son
camp il parlait de bière hier et éthique
de le dire que c'est c'est sympa c'est
sympa que les gens que les que les gens
puissent se rencontrer en vrai quoi que
ce soit pas juste des échanges derrière
derrière des écrans d'ordinateurs donc
je pense je pense qu'on essaye que
d'avoir des thématiques des discussions
intéressantes d'avoir dans les
différents groupes locaux dans lesquels
dans les grandes villes dans lesquelles
il ya un groupe local altruisme efficace
d'avoir des occasions pour les gens
d'échanger en vrai et puis d'avoir une
petite communauté de gens qui sont
vraiment intéressés par ces idées et qui
adhèrent à l'assaut donc il ya une
possibilité d'adhérer gratuitement
altruisme efficace france et pour les
gens qui adhèrent à l'assaut l'idée
c'est d'avoir des événements plus
avancées de ces deux de pouvoir partir
pas juste sur des sur des discussions
très générales sur sur comment ça marche
l'altruisme efficace et et quel type de
2,2 de cause on privilégie actuellement
mais beaucoup plus de se poser des
questions de d'échangés et d'échanger
des idées philosophiques d'échanger des
idées un peu économique aussi et puis et
puis de changer d'avis quand idée l'idée
c'est de deux d'avoir d'avoir une
variété de gens qui peuvent qui peuvent
nous aider à changer d'avis les trucs
assez étrange au début quand des
collègues d'être efficace et que ce que
font les gens dans l'association
c'est beaucoup réfléchir à beaucoup
beaucoup discuté beaucoup échangé ouais
mais je pense que ça c'est vraiment ça
c'est vraiment quand même une des choses
importantes à avoir en tête c'est que
c'est pas que ça c'est il ya beaucoup de
réflexion mais je pense que les gens
s'arrêtent parfois à l'étape de la
réflexion et nous on veut vraiment
encourager les gens à apprendre action
je pense que je vais prendre action je
pense est un anglicisme et à passer à
l'action
je pense que je pense que on essaye je
pense que notre union notre mission avec
avec l'aso c'est d'orienter des
ressources c'est d'orienter des
ressources en temps en argent les
compétences les réseaux que les gens
peuvent avoir vert vers des actions qui
aide réellement les autres et qu'ils
font réellement une différence dans le
monde qui ont un impact dans le monde et
ça je pense que c'est pas c'est pas
perdre de vue je pense que quand on a
toutes ces discussions
sur sur comment bien réfléchir comment
bien pensé comment bien débattre et puis
et puis nous dans l'altruisme efficace
qu est-ce qu on cherche vraiment au fond
qu elles sont quelles sont nos deux
cadres de réflexion moreau quelles sont
les normes épistémique qu'on veut qu'on
veut voir appliquer c'est vraiment super
important de se poser toutes ces
questions mais c'est seulement important
si ça mène rapidement à une de l'action
quand on pense à quoi comme actions
conduites par de l'action je pense qu'il
ya des actions qui peuvent être prises
par les individus par chaque heure
chaque personne quoi je pense que quand
tu prends des décisions sur sur l'argent
que tu donnes et sur le temps que tu que
tu peux donner aussi donc par exemple
des décisions j'en parlais un petit peu
avec avec l'organisation 80 miller des
décisions de choix de carrière qu'est ce
que tu peux faire avec ta carrière pour
pour aider les autres ça l'idée c'est
que à un moment les gens se posent
vraiment ces questions là et puis s'il
voir qu'ils sont dans dans une carrière
qui est qui qui est un peu en conflit
avec leur leurs vidéos et leurs et leur
envie d'aider les autres
bon week-end et que le contexte fait que
c'est possible pour eux de changer tout
ça je pense que c'est pas c'est pas
toujours facile pour tout le monde mais
pour les gens qui ont vraiment ces idées
là et qui ont vraiment envie de dd de
vraiment changer de carrière quoi de
dédit réfléchir très sérieusement et
pareil pour pour les dons c'est pas
juste de comparer dans l'absolu des
interventions des actions différentes de
se poser la question de quelle quelle
intervention est là et la plus efficace
c'est aussi à un moment de dire non pas
voilages et de l'incertitude sur quelle
est l'action la plus efficace mais je
vais donner de l'argent à des à des
organisations qui selon moi pour le plus
de bien possible quoi voilà et ça ça
c'est donc scellé c'est les ressources
un peu basique qu'on peut avoir en tête
quoi que ce soit c'est ça
sa carrière son temps et son argent mais
c'est aussi de développer des nouvelles
compétences pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
aider mieux ça peut aussi être un peu
dans dans la même idée que la carrière
ça peut aussi être de lancer des projets
de lancer une nouvelle asso de de lancer
une chaîne youtube de de lancer une
start up qui essayent de régler un souci
dans le monde
il peut y avoir il peut y avoir des
projets qui sont faits soit la place
soit en parallèle de son de son job
actuel qui peuvent qui peuvent beaucoup
aidé aussi très crue ou cuite hurd a
parlé de pas mal d'associations la très
efficace locale de ce que tu peux y en a
combien aujourd'hui le disent tous les
yeux se trouve en france
en france on en a cinq il me semble donc
paris lyon grenoble toulouse et lille
voilà donc ça c'est dans l'est dans les
différentes villes où il ya actuellement
des gens qui sont qui sont actifs après
si si les tétées viewers sont intéressés
par ailleurs par l'altruisme efficace
depuis un moment et ils sont plusieurs
dans une dans une ville qui veulent
lancer quelque chose on peut on peut en
parler on peut lancer quelque chose avec
avec eux probablement ailleurs aussi et
puis aussi des des groupes étudiants il
ya un groupe altruisme efficace à
polytechnique qui était très récent un
groupe donc à sciences po qui existe
toujours un gros parle à sorbonne à la
panthéon sorbonne je crois ya le n s il
ya plusieurs groupes étudiants sur paris
du coup ceux qui sont intéressés par
l'altruisme efficace qui coûte ce
podcast est vrai mais c'est trop bien
pour que tu conseillerais de pc de
contact et localement ces groupes
d'associations est très difficile de
croire que oui tout à fait et si et si
son ailleurs s'ils sont quelque part où
il n'y a pas de groupe ce qui est
probable étant donné qu'il n'y a que
cinq villes
actuellement il ya des groupes de nous
contacter virtuellement quoi nous
contacter et on a une page facebook on a
un compte twitter on a un mail on a pas
mal de possibilités pour les gens de de
rentrer d'entrer en contact avec nous on
a un site web puis de suivre les
événements c'est de voir certains
événements qui les intéressent pour
participer d'où donc le donc le
mouvement altruisme efficace et ce
quelque chose qui qui grossit qu'en
début d'année déjà ce que tu es d'accord
avec ça et quand tu vois le la
croissance du mouvement alors c'est une
bonne question
oui ça a pas mal grossi autour pendant
les quelques dernières années on est on
est passé alors j'ai peur de dire
n'importe quoi avec les chiffres là je
sais que sur le sait pas exactement ce
que c'est une bonne mesure de qui se
revendique qui fait partie de ce
mouvement altruisme efficace on peut
avoir des idées qui sont très proches
sans forcément connaître connaître le
mouvement ou faire partie de ça mais on
a par exemple la le groupe facebook
effective entre ism qui est qui regroupe
pas mal de gens il ya maintenant seize
mille personnes ce qui est pas ce qui
n'est pas énorme mais je pense qu'il ya
quelques années c'était c'était au tour
de je pense qu'il ya deux ans c'était
c'était plus tôt
autour de deux ou trois mille donc je
les chiffres sont à vérifier aussi mais
oui je pense pas ça quand même pas mal
pas mal gros si on a une grosse
croissance des gens qui ont donc pris le
giving tree cannes pledge la promesse de
donner 10 % de son revenu au cours de sa
vie professionnelle
pas mal de gens qui dînent qui font du
coaching carrière avec avait 80 mille
heures qui viennent aux événements est
très efficace global donc ouais je pense
à ça pas mal grossit et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il ya un peu une
tension dans l'ailé parmi les
organisateurs de groupes locaux et
d'organisations qui se revendique 20 qui
sont inspirées par par ces idées-là
entre le fait de diffuser ses idées dont
les idées peut-être de façon un peu
large que c'est bien d'aider les autres
et que c'est bien de réfléchir de façon
rationnelle et de de changer d'avis et
de u2 d'aider les autres d'une façon qui
soit vraiment kiki qui est vraiment ça
c'est des idées que je pense qu'il est
pas mal la plupart des gens seraient des
seraient d'accord de diffuser pas mal et
par contre pour bien se coordonner pour
avoir une communauté de personnes qui
qui qui est des échanges de qualité
on a moins 7 cette envie de croissance
exponentielle que peuvent avoir d'autres
d'autres groupes d'autres d'autres
mouvements d'autres deux associations
on cherche moins à diffuser nos idées
accueillir le plus de gens possible et
plus à ce que les gens qui sont vraiment
intéressés et qui est qui qui chercha à
s'engager à trouver des ddd ressources
puissent le faire de façon pratique donc
pourquoi est ce que vous voulez pas
grossir exponentiellement sait pas on
n'est pas contre grossière
exponentiellement mais on a moins cet
objectif c'est vrai ce serait vraiment
d'objectif instrumental ce serait
vraiment l'idée l'idée c'est pas que
l'altruisme efficace grandissent de
façon exponentielle et plus que
l'aide dans le monde grandissent de
façon exponentielle donc eux qui au
final mais on est vraiment des
ressources sur les sur les actions les
plus efficaces et ça parfois ça peut
rentrer en conflit on peut se dire que
si si plein de gens par exemple arrivent
avec leurs idées et avec on n'est pas
non pas forcément
le cadre sont intéressés par exemple par
les causes qui sont populaires
actuellement au ca au sein de la truite
efficace mais pas forcément par la
manière de sont pas forcément intéressés
par la manière de penser et de réfléchir
ça peut mener à des soucis à la un peu
d'hooliganisme politique a des gens qui
déforme un peu le message de l'altruisme
efficace et qui au lieu de dire voilà ce
qui est important c'est de bien
réfléchir de se remettre en question et
puis de 2,2 de savoir de savoir quelle
est notre objectif est de réfléchir
petit à petit et comment comment y
arriver
qu'il dise ah j'ai voulu j'ai vu que
vous étiez intéressé par le paludisme
moi aussi je suis intéressé par le
paludisme ou moi aussi je suis intéressé
par par l'intelligence artificielle ou
par par par d'autres d'autres causes par
les animaux d'autre part à l'élevage
industriel c'est des causes qui lui
tiennent à coeur aussi je veux vous
rejoindre voilà les l'idée c'est pas
d'avoir des gens qui nous soutiennent
qu'ils qui pousse la truite mais
efficace où les causes qui sont qui sont
actuellement bien bien représenté dans
l'altruisme efficace en soi et plus
d'avoir voilà des gens qui qui
réfléchissent qui se coordonnent et qui
est qui qui changent les choses dans le
monde et ça c'est ouais c'est pas facile
en fait c'est pas facile d'avoir d'avoir
à la fois de plus en plus de monde qui
qui qui adhèrent qui est intéressé par
ses idées et à la fois de garder un
débat qui soit qu'ils soient de bonne
qualité des échanges qui soit vraiment
intéressant pour tous les participants
et qui qui mène à des actions utiles
parce que le derrière la halle très
efficace et il ya quand même des dents
saines ses désirs de rationalité qui
deux tracés quantitatif et de bien
mesurer les choses qui n'est pas facile
à apprendre et qui voulait surtout pas
perdre enfin vous voulez surtout que le
mouvement soit pas dénaturé et de
conserver vraiment cette partie avec une
croissance un peu rapide y aurait un
risque que que des gens dénature le
message de la très efficace
ouais ouais après après quand tu parles
de deux quantitatif de mesures précises
ou quantitative je pense que ça il ya
potentiellement un quasiment un
stéréotype de l'altruisme efficace qui
qui est que l'on se concentre simplement
sur des interventions qui qui sont
mesurées qui voilà qui dès qu'ils
donnent des résultats qu'on peut qu'on
peut mesurer où tout ce qui nous importe
c'est de calculer quantitativement des
toutes les données qu'on peut qu'on peut
avoir et puis toutes celles qu'on ne
peut pas tout seul comme auxquelles on
n'a pas accès les les données qui sont
un petit peu trop qualitative un petit
peu trop subjective de s'en
désintéresser
et ça je pense que c'est en tout cas
c'est de moins en moins vrai je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de deux causes qui
intéresse les gens dans l'altruisme
efficace ou au contraire c'est très flou
c'est il ya très peu de vraies mesures
c'est très probabiliste les réflexions à
ce sujet là c'est beaucoup plus des des
estimations ou des des ponts et des
estimations que peuvent faire les gens
les différents experts dans un champ sur
sûre qu'est ce qui risque de se passer
et comment est-ce qu'on peut
potentiellement
améliorer les choses et ça c'est pas du
tout calculs minutieux avec avec des
données strictement risques potentiels
oui il ya une partie du ccc un des indes
est une des causes qui intéresse les
gens dans la très efficace est de cesser
la réduction de risques
en gros en gros de risque pour le pour
le futur donc de risque existentiel qui
sont des risques que les choses se
passent très mal pour les pour les
humains futurs ou pour les animaux futur
d'ailleurs dans l'idée de par exemple je
pense que je pense quand une cause que
les gens ont bien en tête la danse ce
serait le changement climatique toi toi
tu parles beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle et c'est effectivement
quelque chose qui m'intéressait
énormément les gens aujourd'hui dans
dans l'altruisme efficace mais pour pour
pour la pour une personne lambda les
risques catastrophiques c'est déjà le le
réchauffement climatique et qu'un risque
vraiment vraiment très important on peut
penser aussi aux risques aux risques
nucléaires au risque de guerre nucléaire
on peut penser au risque de pandémie ya
pas mal de risques différents de chose
qui pourrait se passer qui rendrait la
vie des humains dans le futur
extrêmement mauvaise foi soit qui durait
plein de gens soient qui qui qui
rendrait des conditions de vie
extrêmement extrêmement difficile et ça
toute cette cause là tout s'est tu
tout ce problème de prévention de
certains risques
c'est c'est très flou on a on a on a
très peu d'informations
on ne peut pas juste mesurer
quantitativement on ne peut pas on peut
pas avoir quelques quelques quelques
mesures rapides des geeks qui permettent
de l'arrivée à une conclusion très très
très ferme et les il ya des avis
d'experts qui diverge énormément
le cliquet du coup la part des risques
essentiels quels sont les autres sur les
autres sujets récurrents par exemple de
l'altruisme efficace un délai en gros
souvent on a une division un peu en
trois grandes causes 3 3 grandes trois
grands problèmes toi toi grande quatre
grandes catégories de problèmes -une
c'est là c'est la santé et la pauvreté
de la santé dans les pays en
développement
c'est une cause assez assez large ça se
retrouve pas mal de deux choses mais
l'idée c'est que c'est plus facile
d'attaquer pas mal des soucis qui peut
équiper y avoir de pauvreté dans le
monde à travers des interventions qui
sont focalisés sur la santé et notamment
c'est souvent contrastées avec des
interventions sur l'éducation je pense
que pas mal de gens sont intéressés par
des des interventions sur l'éducation
pour pour éduquer des enfants dans dans
le temps dans certains pays et nous on
se concentre beaucoup plus sur la
réduction de certaines maladies qui
empêche les enfants d'aller à l'école
donc qui font que c'est difficile pour
les enfants d'apprendre et puis qui
causent énormément de morts de
souffrance est typiquement le paludisme
c'en est une mais aussi des maladies
intestinales des vers intestinaux qui
qui sont relativement négligées c'est
décédé voilà c'est un peu de gens qui
s'occupent de ça et il ya énormément de
souffrance de mort et puis probablement
une réduction de la croissance ou de 2
de la capacité des gens à aller à
l'école à aller au travail à cause de
ces à cause de ces maladies une autre
cause qui tient pas mal de gens à coeur
dans l'autre c'est efficace
c'est le
le sort des animaux et en particulier
des animaux d'élevage
il ya peut-être peut-être que je peux
faire une parenthèse s'est passé pas si
c'est clair pour pour pour tout le monde
sur le cadre qu'on utilise pour arriver
un peu à ces conclusions là donc l'idée
dont c'est extrêmement schématique mais
l'idée c'est que pour pour déterminer à
quel point une cause est importante on a
un cadre un peu avec 3 trois critères
fondamentaux qui serait l'ampleur
combien d'individus un problème touche
et à quel point ça les touche
nour on peut se dire par exemple
qu'entre une une maladie orpheline qui
touche quelques personnes dans le monde
chaque année et une maladie comme le
cancer ou hulu le paludisme qui qui
touche énormément de personnes dans le
monde chaque année
il vaut mieux toute chose égale par
ailleurs se concentrait plutôt plutôt
sur celle qui touche le plus de gens et
puis entre une maladie comme comme le
rhume qui touche beaucoup de gens mais
finalement qui est qui et qui
détériorent pas énormément leur qualité
de vie et est une maladie comme comme le
cancer en phase et revoilà cancer en
phase terminale qui qui qui est vraiment
extrêmement extrêmement douloureux pour
pour appeler en appelant dès hier il
vaudrait mieux se concentrer toutes
choses égales par ailleurs encore sur le
sur le sur le cancer
donc ça c'est premier qu'un peu évidente
et voilà l'ampleur du problème et après
on a des critères qui sont moins souvent
utilisés enfin où j'avais j'avais à
moins souvent entendre entendu parler de
ça avant de rejoindre d'avoir ces
idées-là sur sur l'altruisme efficace
c'est le critère de le caractère
négliger d'un problème c'est à dire
est-ce qu'il ya déjà des gens qui
s'occupent de ça qu il ya déjà des gens
qui travaillent sur ce problème dans le
monde est ce que c'est un problème ou si
moi je contribue avec quelques quelques
euros quelques heures de mon temps est
ce que vraiment ça
faire une différence est ce que est ce
que c'est pas déjà complètement sur la
moisissure sur place il a été très très
bon genre qui s'occupe beaucoup de très
bons plans qui s'occupe déjà d'une chose
bon vivre y en aura pas d'autres
contributions va pas changer beaucoup de
choses alors que donc et j'aimerais
juste le troisième le troisième critère
qui serait qui serait à quel point c'est
facile de progresser dans l'avancement
de ce problème on peut être il ya des
causes qui touche l'un des problèmes qui
touchent plein de gens et qu'ils sont
super négligé mais finalement en bossant
dessus nous même c'est pas tellement
comment faire pour pour pour améliorer
les choses
je pense qu'il ya un cas qui intéresse
pas mal à un cas d'étude qui intéresse
pas mal et au moins de façon théorique
des gens d'être efficace pour le moment
qui est le les conditions de vie des
animaux dans la nature des animaux
sauvages et ça on peut se dire bon bah
oui c'est horrible il ya plein de choses
qui qui qui ya plein de souffrance
qu'endurent les animaux sauvages ni au
final qu'est ce qu'on peut y faire nous
sans détruire des écosystèmes sens avec
une connaissance vraiment très très peu
précise de ce que ce que nos actions
pour fr / / / le monde
il vaut mieux pas peut-être mieux passer
avec ce qu'est ou en tout cas pas pas
pas foncer là dedans tête baissée donc
ça c'est un petit peu en regardant ces
trois critères et en regardant comment
un problème se situe sur ces trois sur
ces trois échelles là qu on peut réussir
à comparer des problèmes très différents
et c'est pour ça que donc la santé dans
les pays dits en développement
souvent on considère que c'est pas bon
ça c'est très haut sur ces trois
critères les animaux d'élevage
à partir du moment où elles considèrent
les la souffrance des animaux comme
comme quelque chose de moralement
important et donc je vous renvoie à la
je renvoie les les gens qui écoutent ce
podcast à la superbe vidéo de deux
messieurs filles sur sur ce sujet on
peut on peut comment on peut considérer
que
il ya quand même une voilà quelqu'un
beaucoup d'individus qui sont qui sont
touchés par par ce problème de deux
d'élevage industriel et que finalement c
est tres et très négligée et qu'il ya
pas mal de choses peut-être qu'on peut
faire pour avancer dessus et voilà
et puis les risques catastrophiques
lovers donc pas mal de cause pour
l'intéressé différentes personnes qu
est-ce qui est celui des évolutions sur
les intérêts de dea triste efficace oui
oui énormément
ça ça change vraiment ça changeait
vraiment vraiment beaucoup je pense que
il ya il ya un formulaire un soleil qui
est une enquête qui est réalisé chaque
année pour avoir quelqu'un qui est
distribué un peu à dans tout sur toutes
les plateformes reliés à la truite mais
efficace pour tous les gens qui se
revendiquent de près ou de loin comme
que de 2,2 de la truite efficace pour
pour avoir un petit peu des données sur
la démographie sur les idées que les
gens partagent tout ça est une énorme
évolution ces dernières années vers les
causes qui sont priorisés je pense qu'il
ya quelques années c'était vraiment
surtout des gens qui s'intéressait aux
aux organisations qui sont promus par
guy voile notamment mon dieu tu parlais
de niveau tout à l'heure c'est c'est
c'est une organisation qui compare
différentes différentes directives des
organisations des ong quoi des ong qui
qui travaillent uniquement dans le
domaine du développement international
ouais donc on peut se dire que la
méthodologie qu'utilise qui voit elle
est vraiment
moi je la trouve un moteur qui sont
extrêmement transparents ils sont très
clairs sur leurs doutes et puis ils ont
beaucoup de très bonnes données ils ont
accès à pas mal de très bonnes données
en économie du développement et
lorsqu'ils concernent pas mal de
problèmes différents donc dont je suis
et je fais pas mal confiance omeyer
meilleur
les organisations autochtones altises
promu par parle du voile et je pense que
c'était le cas de pas mal de gens aussi
il ya quelques années et maintenant les
gens continuent à soutenir beaucoup
c'est ces organisations la mecs
concentre beaucoup plus donc sur sur les
risques catastrophiques globaux ou pour
certains sur les les
la souffrance animale epinay m'avait sur
sur d'autres choses il ya une réflexion
maintenant sur la santé mentale dans
l'est dans les pays en développement ou
même dans les pays développés qui
commencent à émerger pas mal qui
commence à devenir un sujet qui
intéresse beaucoup de gens dans
l'altruisme efficace on a aussi des
considérations sur les sur les soins
palliatifs sur sur les grandes
souffrances des gens dans pas mal de
pays qui n'ont pas forcément accès à des
à des soins qu'ils leur des médicaments
en fait killer qui qui qui leur
permettent de d'éviter les grandes
souffrances auxquelles auxquels ils sont
confrontés et sa cdc déçu systématiques
sont un peu nouvelle qui n'existait pas
à voir l'inde et qui on est et qui sont
de plus en plus appréciée par certaines
personnes dans les trousses mais
efficace ce n'était pas le cas avant
donc on reparle de santé mentale c'était
des primes de dépression de plus comme
ça ouais ouais c'est pas mal de c'est
pas mal de soucis différent ça peut être
des des problèmes
donc de dépression d'anxiété différents
différents soucis comme ça mais ça peut
aussi être des la santé mentale la
bipolarité le fait la schizophrénie ça
peut être des fêtes est très large quand
on parle de santé mentale on parle de
plein de choses différentes
hier qu'un mec dans l'altruisme efficace
qui s'appelle michael plaintes qui a
beaucoup travaillé là-dessus car
beaucoup travaillé sur en quoi est-ce
que se focaliser sur les les la santé
mentale ça peut être une cause
prioritaire par exemple dans l'est dans
les pays en développement dans certains
pays en développement où house et où
c'est un tabou ou léo c'est vraiment il
n'ya pas de moyens qui sont mis du tout
sûr sûr sûr c'est sur cette thématique
là comment est-ce que ça peut être une
intervention intéressante hockey prend
pas très bien ces domaines et aimée du
coup quel que soit le type de solution
pour ce problème tu sais pas ce qu'on va
avoir plus de deux psychiatres ou alors
je sais pas exactement c'est une bonne
question j'ai pas lu récemment les
discussions autour de sujets là et
commence à avancer ce qu'il ya dsk
d'aider des interventions qui sont
particulièrement recommandés je sais
qu'il y avait beaucoup de discussions
autour de ça voilà de dire que ça paraît
être un problème important et qui a
probablement des choses qui peuvent être
faites
il semble qu'il ya des organisations qui
avaient été ciblés que les gens
commençaient à regarder d'un peu plus
près à évaluer selon des des critères un
petit peu plus strange en plus tribu les
défis terre déclare défaite des critères
plus stricts et et voilà je sais pas où
en est la réflexion autour des 5
actuellement ok parce que ça une vidéo
récente de deux courtes ce que actes sur
la solitude mais je pense que ça a piqué
plus aux pays développés
mais ça que ça m'a fait pas malheureux
penser ceux là comme étant un problème
assez générales et il ya aussi beaucoup
de discussions mais encore assez et pays
développés sur autour des problèmes
d'addiction notamment aux réseaux
sociaux
c'est l'heure des choses donc moi je ne
suis pas si c'est un truc qui gagne
également très efficace moi je ne sais
pas trop franchement ce serait
intéressant de voir si c'est des
considérations qui sont avec ses révoqué
par certains j'aimerais revenir au
changement climatique qui est qui qui
est pas toujours le sujet prioritaire de
très efficace a expliqué ce qui est des
débats sur sa wii
ouais il ya beaucoup de débat là dessus
ça a été des prioriser surtout à cause
du critère du caractère négliger je
pense que l'argument quand les gens
disent on s'occupe plus d'intelligence
artificielle de sécurité de
l'intelligence artificielle que des
risques liés au changement climatique
c'est surtout parce qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de fonds de volonté politique de
volonté populaire de travailler sur le
problème du changement climatique que
sur d'autres problèmes mais en fait ça
c'est un argument qui est vrai dans une
certaine mesure mais quand comme défini
de façon un petit peu plus granulaire
différentes choses dans le dans le
problème du changement climatique quand
on se dit ok mais les gens se
préoccupent en général des risques liés
à une augmentation de la température de
1 ou 2 degrés mais si on était dans un
scénario extrême ou en fait il y avait
une augmentation de la température d'une
dizaine de degrés est ce que est ce que
est ce qu'il ya des gens qui
réfléchissent à ça qu'est ce que ça
implique
à quoi faire pour pour empêcher ces
risques là il a dessus c'est
probablement plus plus négliger est
pareil peut-être que les les
interventions qui sont qui sont
privilégiés actuellement pour pour
réduire les les soucis liés au
changement climatique
cd c'est pas forcément
les interventions qui sont les plus
efficaces donc peut-être qu'il ya quand
même de la place pour pour des gens qui
réfléchirai à l'impact de leurs actions
différemment kiki puis c'est qu'ils
puissent rentrer dans ce débat là mais
généralement on trouve quand même moi je
bourre général qui a pas mal d'acteurs
très sérieux avec des méthodologies des
dix organisations des think tanks des
des groupes qui réfléchissent déjà aux
problèmes de du changement climatique
d'une façon qui paraît très intelligente
et puis une grosse partie de la
communauté scientifique qui traite de ce
sujet là le fait de manière vraiment
vraiment pertinente quoi donc c'est pas
tellement qu'on pense que c'est un thème
- - portant nez mais juste qu'on pense
qu'il ya des gens qui font ça très bien
et que ajouté notre petite pierre à
l'édifice bas peut-être qu'on n'a pas
grand chose à apporter sur ce sujet là
il ya quand même beaucoup de gens qui
s'intéressent dans le mouvement à
l'international mais aussi en france il
ya de plus en plus de personnes qui de
plus en plus je sais pas mais il ya pas
mal de personnes qui qui s'intéressent à
cette thématique là et donc il ya
beaucoup de discussions il ya beaucoup
de postes là dessus il ya beaucoup 2-2
d'articles de vidéos de des changes à ce
sujet là c'est un sujet qui évite les
potes qui n'est pas négligée par la très
efficace et pas forcément celui qui est
le plus mis en avant c'est ça et donc
dans ces structures donc maintenant un
rôle de directrice exécutive une clique
a été enrôlé galloway
alors mon rôle c'est surtout d'avoir un
staff à plein temps je pense que je fais
un peu un peu je vais beaucoup de choses
très différentes
à la base l'idée c'est de m'occuper de
la coordination des bénévoles des
groupes locaux
nous devons occuper de du community
building donc de tout ce qui est faire
grandir la communauté avoir des des
événements pour pour cette communauté
mais au final on est on est quand même
une petite asso où tout le monde
interagit pas mal donc donc je me
retrouve à travailler directement sur
sur pas mal des projets faire de la
rédaction ou surtout de la relecture de
pas mal de textes et puis de de
travailler sur les les différentes idées
de grands projets qu'on peut avoir au
sein de au sein de l'assaut je passe
aussi une partie de mon temps à parler
avec les gens à faire des d un peu d
entretien personnalisé avec des gens qui
se posent des questions sur sur leur
carrière sur sur leur dos je pense que
c'est plutôt important d'avoir d'avoir
du temps pour ce à quoi de parler
directement avec les gens et de dire
voilà quels sont tes considérations
actuelles qu'elles sont des questions tu
te poses comment est-ce que tu peux y
réfléchir d'une façon différente mais
aussi du coaching de carrière où je
pense que coaching de carrière c'est
c'est peut-être un peu un peu exagéré
comme comme mot par rapport à ce que
c'est c'est gégé pas d' expertise
particulière sur ce sujet là donc c'est
surtout d'aider les gens à réfléchir
donc d'encourager les gens à se poser et
avoir une réflexion sur leur carrière et
de leur fournir des ressources sur
différents sujets de reposer peut-être
de les aider à se poser les bonnes
questions
voilà je pense que je pense qu'il ya des
conseillers d'orientation
il ya du coaching de carrière l'a
peut-être un peu plus professionnel qui
est qui est fait par l'organisation 80
miller dont souvent je redirige les gens
qui veulent un avis un peu plus précis
vers 82 eur voilà moi c'est peut-être un
peu plus informelle et un peu plus
dans l'idée que les gens réfléchissent
eux-mêmes alors à leur carrière 81 alors
c'est quand il y en a où ces intrus
croque-notes ya pas il n'y a pas de
version française
nous on travaille à adapter à certains
de leurs deux lors de certaines de leurs
ressources
on est on a d'ailleurs un projet pour le
moment qui nous enthousiasme pas mal qui
est de fournir des ressources plus
adaptées peut-être aux francophones que
que haïti c'est un scénario mais bon
dans l'idée on reprendrait beaucoup de
leurs suggestions actuelle est peut-être
on aurait des des explications de
comment réussir dans telle ou telle
carrière qui serait mieux adapté à
quelqu'un qui en france ou dans d'autres
pays francophones ou en europe parce qu
on interagit pas mal avec d'autres
groupes locaux en europe et est ailleurs
et c'est un projet qui motive pas mal de
gens de réfléchir à comment comment les
recommandations surtout axée vers les
les américains et vers les britanniques
peut-être vers les australiens un petit
peu comment est ce qu'on peut avoir
avoir des recommandations qui sont plus
pertinentes plus pertinente pour pour
notre public quoi du coup c'est sur les
recommandations que la sfi que de
carrière de 80 mineurs il ya pas mal de
conseils différents ils ont vraiment
j'encourage j'encourage les gens à aller
regarder directement sur sur leur site
ils ont ils ont beaucoup de deux
conseils hyper pratique différents il ya
une partie des conseils qui est
simplement un peu de bon sens mais qui
est l'équipe qui est pas forcément
évidente qui est qu'ils peuvent être par
exemple si si on en a envie de
travailler d'avoir une carrière qui peut
aider les autres pour pour aider les
autres c'est pas forcément
optimal de commencer ce pas forcément le
mieux de commencer avec à travailler
dans une ong de s'engager directement
dans une ong
on peut se dire que il ya des choses à
faire en en étudiant déjà en en se
formant davantage pour avoir des
compétences qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
plus utile dans l'est dans les champs
con con dans lesquels on veut aider
il ya une grosse partie du message de 80
miller qui est aussi de se poser la
question sur ce qu'on sait que ce qu'on
considère être important c'est cette
réflexion sur sur les causes sur la
comparaison des problèmes et des causes
bah c'est peut-être à avoir en amont
peut-être de continuer tout au tout au
long de sa vie mais en tout cas c'est
peut-être à avoir le plus tôt possible
pour pouvoir diriger ses efforts et et
cesser sa formation vers vers les causes
qu'on imagine être le plus important les
plus importantes on n'a pas forcément
besoin des mêmes comme des mêmes
compétences pour pour travailler sur des
délais de là pour coder des dd il ya
bénéfiques ou pour travailler dans dans
le changement climatique ou pour
travailler dans la santé la pauvreté un
global c'est pas forcément les mêmes
études ni les mêmes les mêmes
compétences dont il a besoin
donc ça c'est vraiment une
recommandation un peu un peu clé de 80
mille heures de daytona où tu es et puis
et puis après voilà donc dans leurs
recommandations ils peuvent
il conseille aux gens de de réfléchir
même de façon un peu contre intuitive à
ce qui peut ce qui peut être utile pour
aider les autres par exemple de dire bon
ben voila si si vous êtes actuellement
dans vous avez actuellement un job qui
vous plaît beaucoup
ou vous gagnez beaucoup d'argent vous
n'avez pas forcément envie de changer de
job vous n'avez pas forcément envie de
passer de passer à autre chose mais est
ce que vous pouvez considérer
donner une grosse partie de vos revenus
à des adecco efficace de dire mais aussi
de l'espace et aussi de la place pour
des gens qui sont déjà bien engagés dans
une dans une voie ou dans une carrière
ou qui ont la capacité de travailler
dans un champ dans un dans un domaine
oui oui pourrait gagner beaucoup
d'argent
il ya une possibilité pour ces gens là
contribuent de façon vraiment
significative en fait aux causes les
plus importantes aux causes qui leur
tiennent à coeur
simplement en redonnant une grosse
partie de leurs revenus on peut imaginer
que si on tient on est trader et que on
donne je sais pas 10% pour commencer
mais pour les gens qui sont vraiment
très impliquée dans ses idées et pas
exemptes très impliqué là dedans et qui
font ça pour aider les autres avant tout
penaud imaginer donner 50 % ou dans le
cas de certaines collectes dans le cas
de certaines personnes dans le mouvement
90 % de leurs revenus
voilà de travailler à google com com
software développeur et puis de redonner
mois et 90 % de son revenu adéquat et
efficace et en faisant ça on peut
embaucher
finalement trois ou quatre personnes au
moins ont plutôt plutôt que de s'engager
directement dans une ong
donc ça c'est un peu d'aidé réflexion à
voir qui sont contre intuitive
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas quelque
chose qui est qui est bien pour tout le
monde je pense que il y avait un peu
aussi un détournement de ce message là
un moment où seront disait voilà pour
preuve guerrière et picasso il était un
peu dit voilà la triste efficace
recommande de juste aller bosser dans la
finance et puis de redonner son argent
c'est pas vrai et il ya surtout des
réflexion à avoir sur sur à quel point
nous notre emploi peut avoir un impact
négatif aussi si on bosse par exemple
dans une fabrique d'armes bon bout on
bosse pour fabriquer des armes et on est
tout autant de redonner 90% de son
dessous revenus à des causes efficace
peut-être que c'est pas super de
contribuer à la production
je sais pas ça dépend des malheurs des
uns et des autres mais non pas en tout
cas on peut se poser des questions sur
sûr sûr sûr certains sur certains
boulots qui sont négatifs de même point
ouais
et donc aujourd'hui tu es la seule
employée de la crise mais on travaille
avec avec pas mal de bénévoles attend
donc le banc pendant les deux années à
les trois années avant avant d'être
embauché j'aime agité bénévoles et là
qu'on a une équipe d'une vingtaine de
bénévoles qui sont hyper impliqués qui
bossent souvent autant plus que moi 1
salle d'eau une seule employée mais
beaucoup de gens qui bossent beaucoup de
membres
on a pas mal de membres en avant je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire pas mal
d'ailleurs c'est super c'est très
subjectif mais on a je pense qu'on doit
être autour de 270 ou peut-être 300
membres et qui sont des gens qui sont
partout en france et on a fait un
sondage récemment pour avoir un petit
peu plus d'avoir une meilleure idée de
qui sont nos membres
tout ça c'est vraiment intéressant en
fait c'est des gens très différents avec
des centres d'intérêts variés qui sont
intéressés à la truite mais efficace de
différentes manières oui c'est très
chouette cdc des gens des gens super et
on les voit on les voit quand on fait
des événements réservés aux membres des
ateliers pour les membres et puis des
rencontres sociales pour les membres et
et c'est vraiment c'est super
intéressant quoi c'est des gens qui
discutent de façon vraiment informé qui
voit c'est chouette
-selon chouette et donc utiliser que les
avaient des profils assez différent ce
que fait parler un peu de alors des
profils assez différent je pense qu'il
faut pas non plus se leurrer ça reste ça
reste quand même assez homogène
graphiquement on a surtout des hommes on
a quand même une grande majorité
d'hommes
je pense une grande majorité d'hommes
blancs on a beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent dans l'informatique beaucoup
de mathématiciens des philosophes
il ya quand même les gens qui sont
intéressés par ces idées peut-être que
c'est aussi le type de gens qui aillent
bien tes vidéos je sais pas trop mais
souvent je sais pas je sais pas si tu as
des stats passe à quoi ça correspond au
descriptif des cas on en a
on a quand même des gens qui se
ressemblent pas mal sûr sous certains
sur certains aspects mais pas que c'est
vraiment chouette de aussi d'avoir des
gens très différents des gens qui sont
juste hyper intéressé à la base par ce
n'est pas par le bien-être animal donc
cédé des militants animalistes il ya des
des gens qui travaillent en économie du
développement agipal qui font de la
recherche en date à science pour pour
découvrir et à quelle quelle qu'elle
soit intervention qui marche bien qu'ils
font déjà ça ou kim qui bossent
directement sur le terrain dans une ong
on a quand même on a quand même des
universités de profil et c'est super
intéressant parce que parce que des
expertises qui vont donc le profit que
vous avez peu plus ciblées bah c'est
compliqué parce que le si tu veux dire
dans la source donc au dedans comme
membre de l'asso pas forcément quoi on
en a chaque personne qui intéressait qui
veut contribuer ses compétences à elle
c'est chouette c'est super mais
évidemment dans le mouvement de
l'altruisme efficace plus plus plus
généralement et puis encore plus encore
plus généralement juste dans les gens
qui aident les autres bien sûr il ya
besoin de plein de compétences
différentes
il ya besoin besoin de de gens qui ont
fait qu'ils ont fait de l'art et de la
biologie ou de la médecine qui sont
capables de 2,2 de comprendre les
risques de lait bio risque les pandémies
et tout ça on a besoin d'eux de gens qui
qui a fait de la politique des relations
internationales qui sont qui peuvent qui
peuvent s'occuper des soucis de
gouvernance mondiale ou de de
gouvernance même nationale et qui
peuvent qui peuvent influencer qui
peuvent qui peuvent agir en fait au
niveau du gouvernement pour pour que
pour que les gouvernements
aussi puissent être aient puis celle des
acteurs importants dans ned les deux
autres dans les différents champs amis
donc ça c'est un peu on peut vraiment
imaginer que le plus plus grande
diversité de profils soient soit
vraiment parce que les mathématicien et
philosophe c'est beau mais la diversité
et donc les quels sont les grands
projets très efficace france aujourd'hui
alors on a suscité ce projet là qui est
qui qui nous motive pas mal ce serait un
projet sur les sur les carrières serait
d'avoir d'avoir un os soit pas forcément
à l'équivalent de 80 milliards d'actifs
airways ont continué à pas mal d
dépendre de ce que de ce que au fond
mais mais en tout cas de dalles joue un
âge où un complément à 80 mille heures
on est aussi intéressé par des projets
qui seraient plus du conseil un peu plus
ciblée d'aller voir des des grands
philanthropes d'aller voir d'aider des
fondations d'entreprises ou des
fondations en général et de et de
réfléchir avec ces personnes là à
quelles sont leurs contraintes et
comment est ce qu ils peuvent appliquer
à un cadre un cadre une certaine
méthodologie pour réfléchir à voilà qu
est-ce qui peuvent orienter de l'argent
la façon la plus efficace possible
vous avez des contacts avec ces
fondations un peu ça dépend ça dépend
lesquels on a on a déjà fait une petite
présentation à la bnp la la la fondation
de la bnp et puis c'est le service de
dow management de la bnp nous avait
demandé en 2010 est je crois de leur
faire une petite présentation / / / / /
la truite mais efficace mais de façon
générale on ad on a pas mal de gens qui
sont déjà en fait intéressé par ces
idées là on a des gens dans des trucs
efficaces qui sont des grands d'écran ou
des déjà des gens d'en bas en tout cas
dans les réseaux de différentes
personnes en route mais efficace qui
sont des grands donateurs et qui sont
déjà plutôt convaincu par ces idées là
mais qui ont besoin d'eux
dead pour réfléchir à en pratiquer ou
est-ce qu'ils dirigent leur argent non
et donc les autres projets je découpe
les ventes à la non mais on a pas mal de
choses qu'on imagine donc on imagine
pouvoir faire mais on essaye de de se
restreindre un petit peu de spécialiser
un peu un peu haut niveau mais tu as de
ce qu'on essaye de faire avec avec
l'altruisme efficace en général qui est
de prioriser entre les différentes
causes de se dire bien sûr il ya plein
de problèmes possibles dans le nez il ya
plein de choses qu'on aimerait vouloir
faire mais au final on a des ressources
limitées et il faut il faut choisir un
peu je pense qu'on essaye d'appliquer la
même chose à nous même de dire bien sûr
ya plein de choses qu'on pourrait
imaginer vouloir faire qu'est-ce que
avec les profils qu'on a actuellement
les les les compétences de l'argent
qu'on a qu'on actuellement qu'est ce qui
pourrait être le plus le plus efficace
et cette idée de rester une plateforme
pour pour la communauté de d'aider les
gens à diriger leur leur temps et leur
et leur argent
et cette idée d'avoir du contenu en
français de qualité qu'ils soient
accessibles et en particulier sur tout
ce qui est carrière ça c'est vraiment
nos grandes priorités pour moi est-ce
que vous avez des liens avec les autres
êtres inefficaces les autres
associations attribuent efficaces
d'autres pays pardon oui mais carrément
ouais on est on est très en lien très
proche on échange souvent souvent avec
eux pour voir ce que ce que font comment
est-ce qu'on peut s'aider mutuellement
est ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont
résolu des problèmes que nous on peut
avoir ou vice versa moi je suis financer
mon salaire ça vient du center for
effective à cesena à oxford qui
financent aussi de la même façon qui
fait des grottes pour pour des
organisateurs de différents groupes
locaux en europe notamment et
et un des bénéfices d'avoir ce g c'est
qu'on peut se coordonner au score donné
pas mal on a des on a cela comme google
groups et ça permet d'échanger sur les
bonnes pratiques à différents endroits
du coup les est ce que les différentes
associations a trait aux applications
différentes spécificités locales parfois
en général le l'idée reste la même
parfois il ya des projets je sais qu'à
singapour par exemple il travaillait sur
sur un projet sur sur les organisations
efficace en asie du sud-ouest sud-est
pardon qui ouais je pense que parfois
certains groupes se concentre sur sur
leurs avantages comparatifs sur
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce
qu'il ya dans un pays qui aurait pas
forcément ailleurs
mais l'idée l'idée générale reste la
même - peut-être à genève aussi ils ont
comme tu sais qu'à genève yari un groupe
aussi altruisme efficace et et eux ils
ont une dominante politique parce qu'ils
se connaissent ont quand même à un
endroit où où il ya pas mal
d'organisation nationale il se concentre
sur les les ressources auxquelles ils
ont accès à genève auquel auquel
d'autres d'autres routes n'aurait pas
forcément accès qu au cours des
dernières années est ce quelque chose à
dire on fait ça pas bien il faut qu'on
progresse sur certains points quels sont
les points sur lesquels penser qu'elle
plus de progrès possible
ouais ça c'est une bonne question je
pense que c'est hyper important la
question des erreurs et de quelle
comment on peut s'améliorer dans
l'altruisme efficace et pas mal
d'organisation qui qui font partie de ce
mouvement là qui ont même une page sur
leur site web qui s'appelle anne stakes
et qui essaye d'être le plus transparent
possible sur les les problèmes gros ou
petits qu'ils ont pu avoir au cours de
leur existence c'est super intéressant
d'ailleurs je recommande d'aller d'aller
lire les screens n est pas ce que parce
que voilà et puis il explique comment
ici comment est-ce qui se corrigent
comment quelques l information ils ont
vu qu'il est qu il
on fait changer d'avis sur sur sur
certaines pratiques qui pouvait avoir et
puissant diab a finalement on pourrait
faire ça mieux et c'est vrai c'est vrai
dans le vrai plus généralement dans
cette communauté là il ya beaucoup de
deux posts de blog par exemple avec
quelqu'un qui dit bon ben voila j'ai
remarqué que de façon systématique dans
l'altruisme efficace et on art ce biais
là et puis dans le commentaire là dessus
et puis les gens change quoi c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment super super
étonnant d'ailleurs ça faisait chaud
qu'à chaque fois quand il ya des vrais
il ya des ya des vrais changements il ya
des vrais des choses qui sont mises en
place
là on parlait de diversité tout à
l'heure le du fait que malgré tout ça
reste une communauté de gens assez
homogène et ça il ya eu pas mal de
critiques là dessus en interne beaucoup
de gens qui disaient mais attention quoi
on risque d'avoir une vision du monde
qui est complètement biaisé si c'est une
vision de mecs blancs élite de certaines
petites d'un petit groupe d'universités
cesser ces problématiques et et après à
partir de là c'est vraiment devenu ça
fait partie des objectifs les plus mises
en avant dans papa m'a pas mal
d'organisation d'organisateur de groupes
locaux de s'intéresser à universel
profil l'univers cette façon de penser
de de profil intellectuel aussi de ne
pas avoir seulement des gens qui font
justement des maths ou de la philo mais
aussi plus des gens qui font des
sciences sociales plus de gens qui qui
ont aidé des expertises un peu
différente ou qui ont des profils
atypiques ou d où des compétences doit
des compétences variées et ça ça c'est
sympa quoi vous allez réfléchir à des
stratégies pour effet d'attirer je sais
pas des filles de son social web il ya
des stratégies de communication donc par
exemple si on poste nos événements plus
dans des temps des groupes de gens qui
font des sciences sociales dans des
groupe d'universités ou d'e mailing list
de gens qu'on essaye de cibler
spécifiquement basse est plus probable
que ces gens déjà entendre parler de
nous on a aussi des dans l'altruisme il
ya des gens dans l'altruisme efficace
qui ont créé des groupes facebook qui
sont réservés aux femmes dans
l'altruisme efficace aux gens de couleur
dans les trucs efficaces qui est un
groupe facebook s'appelle diversity and
thank lui je n ai fait qu tevez filet
qui réfléchissent à plein de solutions
de choses qu'on peut faire de façon de
parler aussi peut-être qu'il ya des
départs fois des façons de parler qui
peuvent rebuter certaines personnes ou
du jargon qu'on utilise donc peut-être
diminuer un petit peu le niveau de
jargon d'expliquer quand on parle de
quelque chose de bien montrer à notre
notre niveau de certitude pour pas pour
pas apparaître comme arrogant ou ça ça
c'est pas mal de monde et des bonnes
pratiques de façon générale mais c'est
aussi des choses qui peuvent rebuter
plus certains profils que d'autres non
et puis après il ya des questions
basiques de six ont par exemple d'avoir
des événements qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient accessibles
c'est de réfléchir c'est pas toujours le
cas on n'y arrive pas toujours mais mais
d'avoir des événements qui permettent
avec beck permettent à des gens avec
certains types de handicap d'accéder à
nos événements bat déjà ça interdit -
ces personnes-là de venir vous dire on
pourrait vraiment faire faire beaucoup
plus mais yahia en tout cas en tout cas
c'est une réflexion qui est et qui
présente toi c'est ça fait l'analogie
avec les mathématiques ou il ya façon de
parler des mathématiciens qui avait qui
est assez cassante est à ces médias
c'est un jargon plus très cassantes et
très une condescendance assez naturel de
pas mal de gens mathématiques qui a ses
problématiques pour l'apprentissage est
magique et couvertures des mathématiques
je sens qu'elle ne cherche souvent l'été
il a parlé de quelques quelques
associations qui qui listait des erreurs
ce que tu as des exemples
d'erreur intéressante alors jeu j'en ai
pas fait je pense que c'est souvent des
choses très spécifiques que j'ai en tête
par exemple je pense que guy voix elle y
voit elle a changé d'avis sur sur
certaines choses ils ont ils ont changé
d'avis sur les critères qu'ils
utilisaient ils ont changé d'avis sur
alors notamment ils ont ils sont appuyés
pour recommander une organisation je
sais plus laquelle s'était d'ailleurs
mais c'est pour pour vous recommander
une organisation et sont appuyés sur un
sur un air c'était sur une étude
contrôlée une étude de lise et contrô le
et randomisée et kiki c'est après avéré
être être des données qui étaient
quittés pas super fiable et donc à la
fois l'organisation elle même qui est
unique et donc qui s'inspire des mêmes
principes a tout de suite montré ce
problème là et a dit bon ben voilà on va
on va on va arrêter notre programme qui
qui qui est là pour compenser être très
efficace parce qu'il avait été évalué
d'une façon qui était qui était pas top
on va on va arrêter ça on va enfin
passer à d'autres d'autres programmes
avec les sur les sur lesquels on est on
est plus risqué auquel on est plus
confiant et guy voit elle aussi a dû
publier à l'explication du pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils s'étaient trompés à ce
moment là qu'est ce qu'ils allaient
faire pour pour pour être sûr qu'ils se
tromperait pas de la même façon
systématique en tout cas de façon
systématique dans le futur ouais donc
succès un test au randomisée contrôlée
qu'ils avaient faits qui alors c'est pas
donc give one give ont elles fait pas de
test randomisés contrôlés ils s'appuient
sur des études d'autres gens sondés sur
des chercheurs en économie qui font des
études
et puis certaines certaines études sont
moins fiables que d'autres camps ont des
problèmes statistiques fondées
il ya des soucis dans la réplication
ne fonctionne pas scott il y aura des
joueurs des erreurs classiques de gens
qui essaient souvent c'est sur la tribu
efficace et à tout à l'heure je
mentionnais un peu le côté on in to give
dans curling et c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle le l'idée d'aller dans des dans
des carrières ou ans mais c'est beaucoup
d'argent pour en redonner et c'est
vraiment c'était devenu un cliché de
l'actrice mais efficace à une époque où
finalement les legends entendez parler
de ça avant avant que enfin avant
d'entendre le reste des idées et puis
puis voilà je sais quand quelqu'un
entende n'est pas de l'altruisme
efficace dit ah bah oui mais en fait ce
que vous voulez c'est qu'on aille tous
dans la finance et pour redonner une
partie de leurs revenus alors que alors
que vraiment pas vous peut-être
peut-être qu'à l'époque c'était vrai
d'ailleurs je dis vraiment pas mais
peut-être qu'il y avait un accent qui
était mis là dessus qu'ils étaient qui
était plus important à l'époque et que
c'est pas juste les gens qui
interprétait mal c'était réellement les
idées promues par 80 dealers ou
l'altruisme efficace qui tournait un peu
trop autour de ça peut-être peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui on peut se dire qu'on a
un billet vert ces histoires de
d'intelligence artificielle on l'a on a
trouvé un filon un truc con donc on
pense à être super important justifie
hyper bien mais au final il ya aussi
beaucoup de gens dans l'altruisme
efficaces qui sont déjà à la base des
informaticiens qui sont déjà des gens
qui s'intéressent à ces problématiques
peut être qu'on peut se dire que si les
gens lit automatiquement à altruisme
efficace et risques risques liés à une
intelligence artificielle super super
intelligente bas peut-être que ça aussi
c'est un peu un billet qu'on a et que
dans quelques années on se rendra compte
que quand on a trop mis l'accent là
dessus bon je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
parieurs en externe et en interne il ya
beaucoup de critiques et a beaucoup de
gens qui disaient la tension est ce que
est ce qu'on se concentre pas trop sur
sûr c'est le truc
voilà voilà voilà toutes les raisons
pour lesquelles on pourrait ne pas se
concentrer là dessus et se concentrer
sur tel autre chose à la place donc je
suis pas trop inquiète de ça parce qu'il
ya une grosse réflexion en permanence
autour de ces questions là mais il
n'empêche que c'est c'est possible quoi
une attitude un peu à la remise en cause
c'est récurrent tués
très souhaitable comment est-ce que tu
verrais comment est-ce que tu voi
l'altruisme efficace évoluer dans le
futur ça va sauver l'humanité ou pas
ouais je sais pas trop je sais que c'est
bien de faire des prédictions dans le
futur je suis très d'accord avec ça mais
je j'ai beaucoup de mal à gg plein de
scénarios possibles en tête et j'ai
beaucoup de mal à me dire ah bah c'est
ça qui va se passer avec la plus grande
probabilité je peux dire ce que ce que
ce que j'espère c'est ce que j'espère
que ça va ça va se développer que ça va
devenir la norme que les les
gouvernements ou les individus quand ils
prennent des décisions sur sur sur les
sur leurs dons sur leur carrière ou sur
leurs politiques face à face à le
fassent de manière raisonnée réfléchi
avec une approche avec steve mickson mai
mais ça c'est pas forcément ce que je
prédis quoi c'est ce que c'est ce que
j'aimerais essai c'est vers ça que je
tends et c'est un peu compliqué avec ses
prédictions là c'est qu'il ya il ya
c'est un peu circulaire j'ai
l'impression que c'est aussi mon action
où notre action qui qui qui qui va mener
plus ou moins vers des relais les
scénarios qu'on espère donc c'est un peu
si si je fais des prédictions
aujourd'hui mais que j'ai influence avec
avec les actions c'est compliqué de
savoir si si ça te motive encore plus à
certains tu faisais pas trahi et non du
coup ça te paraît probable que dès que
des politiciens raisonne en terme
d'ampleur n'est qu'un quart négliger
solvabilité ça me paraît probable que
qui prennent plus en compte ou que ce
que ce soit que ce soit plus voulu par
l'opinion publique que les politiques
soient soit soit mieux évaluer je pense
que je pense que c'est ouais c'est
probable que de plus en plus par exemple
l'agencé française du développement qui
en partie fait partie de l'état un peu
c'est aaa maintenant un département sur
sur l'évaluation et place plus de
ressources et d'attention surévalué les
interventions à laquelle lakh elle
promeut je pense que ça ce mouvement-là
de davantage évaluer ses politiques il
ya une évaluation du cic eux qui avaient
carrick qui était un peu ambivalente
mais qui était plutôt plutôt négative
est qui et qui a permis d'arrêter ou en
tout cas de changer le modèle de cette
cette politique là je fais c'est que le
cce s'est donc c'est le crédit il faut
oublier ce que celle-ci et cible mais
crédit d'impôt blabla entreprises
compétitivité pour l'acro compétitivité
l'emploi peut-être créé des crédits
d'impôt crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité
ok wen le 6 et enfin je ne voudrais pas
trop je voudrais pas trop rentrer dans
les détails parce que j'ai j'y suis allé
à une conférence sur le sujet il ya
trois ans maintenant donc je pense que
il ya deux ans donc je pense que c'est
probablement moi mais mes connaissances
là dessus sont limitées mais met en en
gros l'idée c'était que c'était une
offre fiscales faites faites aux
entreprises qui est qui embauchait des
salariés une déduction fiscale pour les
entreprises
et ça a été ça a été évaluée super
rigoureusement il ya eu trois équipes de
chercheurs je crois qu'ils ont chacun
fait mener des évaluations indépendantes
ou ou en tout cas par des méthodes
différentes sais pas quel point c'était
indépendant qui après ont comparé leurs
résultats et qui sont qui est qu'ils
sont qui sont arrivés à des conclusions
un petit peu différente qui ont réfléchi
à pourquoi ce qu'elles sont arrivés à
des conclusions différentes qu'elles
étaient les résultats qu'on pouvait
vraiment tirer tirer de ça les
conclusions qu'on pouvait vraiment en
tirer et fin c'est super quoi s'il ya
plus de choses comme ça qui se met en
place
c'est chouette et j pal donc le sait le
poverty action lab du radium haïti donc
c'est un réseau de chercheurs qui fait
justement d d
étude randomisée et contrôlée hier
c'était eux ils ont les eaux toute une
partie qui s'occupe de deux conseillers
les décideurs publics
ils ont d'ailleurs une identité est
maintenant un peu un peu séparés qui
s'occupe de ça et ça c'est super aussi
je veux dire même dans des pays au lieu
que ce soit que tout soit fait par des
des fondations privées ou des des
organisations des organisations
caritatives que les que les
gouvernements eux-mêmes regarde ce qui a
le plus d'impact et et appliquent des
politiques à grande échelle c'est
vraiment très encourageant ça c'est
super du coup je pense que c'est une
culture de ce genre de vouloir faire ce
lors des analyses qui est en train de
grandir ou de se propager petit à petit
oui c'est vrai j'ai vraiment peur sur ce
sujet choix choix superbe disais quoi je
je je moi je vois là où ça se propage je
vois pas forcément tous les endroits où
ou et ouais je sais pas trop je j'espère
moi je dirais je dirais plutôt oui mais
je pense que je suis pas très sûr sinon
de façon plus ce que je quitte donc il
est un peu d'huile être efficace avec
peut parler un peu plus de toit
personnellement comment est ce que tu
t'es un fort mais quand est-ce que tu tu
réfléchis de façon bah moi j'aime bien
voir des des sources d'infos sur
l'actualité quand même je vais pas et
j'étais vraiment très intéressé par ce
que vous disiez avec avec christophe
michel sur le fait de se séparer un
petit peu de se distancer un petit peu
de l'actualité en continu parce que
parce que finalement ça permet pas
beaucoup de prendre du recul
moi je trouve ça très intéressant de
voir ce à quoi les gens ce qui ce qui
intéresse les gens
actuellement et ceux qui ce dont les
gens parlent au jour le jour ne pas être
complètement déconnecté
des sujets d'intérêt des des gens de
pouvoir de pouvoir de pouvoir comprendre
comment comment évolue la société aussi
de commande pas en tout cas en tout cas
comment évaluez-vous évalue
l'information à laquelle a accès à une
grande partie de la population sache
vraiment intéressant donc je me
renseigne avec des sources d'infos
diverses jeux j'écoute rfi j'ai des
notifications le monde j'étais j'aimais
beaucoup courrier international un
moment j'ai déjà plusieurs journaux
étrangers aussi pour essayer d'avoir de
l'actu un petit peu diverses sur sur
tout le reste surtout ce qui est plus
sujet de fond j'ai l'impression que
j'apprends beaucoup en parlant avec des
gens j'ai l'impression que moi ma
manière d'apprendre préféré c'est de
parler avec quelqu'un qui est vraiment
experts dans son sujet de lui poser
plein de questions de vieira non je
comprends pas je comprends toujours pas
vas-y avec moi une troisième fois et de
voir si après je peux peut être
reformulée ce qu'il a dit ou ce qu'elle
a dit 2pour pour pour avoir une
meilleure compréhension une
compréhension très fine d'un sujet ça
c'est quelque chose que j'aime vraiment
beaucoup faire et j'ai beaucoup appris
comme ça et c'est un jugement de parler
à des gens comme ça ouais je suis
entouré de gens vraiment vraiment
passionnant basse et c'est surtout le
cas en philo par exemple j'ai pas
forcément un background en philo alors
que je passe beaucoup de temps à
réfléchir à des à des problèmes éthiques
et sa de parler avec avec des
philosophes ou avec des amis
doctorant en philo c'est génial quoi ça
fait vraiment il parle avec plusieurs
personnes différentes bien sûr ne pas
avoir toujours la même vision mais de
d'avoir d'avoir quelqu'un qui explique
en détail son sujet de thèse
un paper un paper spécifique c'est
cesser de set up donc çà çà çà çà çà me
permets de d'apprendre pas mal je lis
beaucoup je regarde un peu des vidéos
youtube j'écoute un peu des podcasts
mais je préfère je pense je préfère le
plus format
article quoi le format passe-passe de
blogs qui me permet de deux sauté au
passage que je trouve le plus
intéressant de surligner de prendre des
notes
j'aime vraiment beaucoup en fait marc
formés à travers des ddd forum des des
blogs des blogs d'experts ou de blocs de
gens avec des des avis des positions
assez contre intuitive sur sur
différentes choses voilà et puis après
d'enjeux je n'utilise plus facebook et
twitter donc moi me mama source d'infos
qui serait qu'ils seraient les way ce
serait plutôt facebook c'est d'avoir des
laits les opinions des gens sur sur un
sujet où des partages de sources
coquelles ggp afin que j'ai pas
forcément l'habitude de voir ouais j'ai
beaucoup facebook c'est plus le nude ou
est-ce que ce fossé quoi sur surpasser
les deux en fait cédé nous suivent nous
ce média il ya les groupes qui je reçois
l'actualité des différents groupes
auxquels quelques abonnés dans mon
yousfi directement je passe probablement
un peu trop de temps à se caler sur le
newsfeed comme comme elle la plupart de
mes sur le mais c'est vraiment en fait
je trouve ça super intéressant notamment
quand quand on a des amis dans
différents pays qui poste par exemple
des des journaux qui passe d' aider des
sources dax d'actu qui sont différentes
de celles que j'ai l'habitude de lire ou
qui postent leurs perspectives sur
quelque chose qui se passe dans leur
pays
ggd ami va partir et sur l'amérique
latine j'ai des amis des musées lien
colombien brésilien qui qui qui postent
très régulièrement des leurs
perspectives de ce qui se passe dans
leur pays et ça c'est vraiment très très
différente de ce que je peux lire dans
l'actuelle françaises ou américaines ou
britanniques
ça ouais ça chante ça très intéressant
du coup tu parle portugais et espagnols
je parle
oui je parle parle parle pas à quel
point avec les points je parle
couramment mais je je je comprends très
bien
pagnol et puis et puis le portugais
aussi chouette et donc est ce que tu as
dans ton évolution des idées est ce
qu'il y avait des trucs
comment est-ce que ça a évolué au cours
des cinq dernières années une fois deux
dernières années c'est ce qu'a débuté ce
que des gros changements particuliers
bah j'ai l'impression que oui j'ai
l'impression que surtout j'ai appris des
trucs fous que que je savais pas donc
c'était même pas né s'est pas pas
forcément des choses où j'avais un avis
avancer des choses qui sont rentrés dans
mon champ des savoirs il ya quand même
certains ouais il ya certaines choses ou
g où j'ai vraiment beaucoup évolué et je
pense que c'est surtout vrai sur tout ce
qui est à nîmes au je pense que moi moi
je suis rentré dans dans tout ce qui
était un truisme efficace via les
humains la pauvreté les problématiques
de souffrance humaine et je trouvais pas
que les animaux fin c'était pas quelque
chose où je m'étais vraiment posé la
question quoi je vous avais des amis
végétariens que je trouvais même un peu
un peu bizarre je vous rappelle le au
brésil j'avais j'avais des amis
végétarienne se trouvait quasiment ça je
trouvais presque c'est un manque de
respect quoi de d'apporter leur leurs
principes moraux occidentaux et puis de
de ne pas goûter la nourriture locale à
base de viande tout ça je comprenais
vraiment pas quoi c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui était très loin de mes
préoccupations
et puis et puis au fur et à mesure en
rencontrant pas mal de gens qui qui
avait les mêmes préoccupations de moi
que moi sur 99% des sujets sauf ça et en
écoutant vraiment des arguments que je
trouvais vraiment vraiment vraiment top
quoi j'ai complètement changé d'avis
là-dessus quoi je le maintenant je pense
que les mois je pense que énormément de
d'animaux non humains qui sont qui sont
sentis ans et je pense que c'est très
important de contribuer à réduire leurs
souffrances
ouais ça franchement c'est quelque chose
que j'ai beaucoup évolué ce que tu as
des points de désaccord avec les
consensus de la triste figure de
scepticisme ouais bah
ouais comme je te disais je trouve ça
vraiment un il ya des points de
consensus mais il ya tellement
divergences il a tellement il ya
toujours des espèces de deux courants
différentes qui s'opposent avec 10 voix
il y aurait plusieurs petits consensus
quoi il ya plus il ya pas mal de gens
qui discutent en permanence et qui sont
toujours pas forcément d'accord sur tout
en particulier tout ce qui est d or et
morale quoi on peut on peut vraiment
vraiment avoir des avis complètement
différent sur sur complètement on arrive
à des choses différentes que même sur ce
qu'il faut valoriser en priorité et oui
il est là dessus je j'ai ouais je sais
pas je vois rien ou où tout le monde
pense quelque chose ou en tout cas la
grande majorité des gens pensent quelque
chose et moi je suis persuadé du
contraire ça c'est mort il me semble fok
corrige mois ci est en effet que dans la
très efficace et quand même un gros
penchant pour le conséquent civisme
ouais donc ça serait ce sera un
consensus en tout cas ouais mais là
dessus moi je suis plutôt d'accord je
suis plutôt ça c'est quelque chose avec
lequel je suis je suis plutôt
confortable la course aux conséquences
alisme donc ouais donc donc l'idée que
ce qui est important avant tout pour
juger de si quelque chose est bien et
mal une action est bonne ou mauvaise
c'est les conséquences que cela peut
avoir
ça je suis plutôt convaincu je pense que
je pense que ça peut être je pensais
peut être nuancer quoi je pense que dans
certains cas c'est bien d'avoir des
règles qui dans certains cas on a
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur quelles
seront les conséquences d'une action et
c'est pas mal de d'avoir des règles
genre ne pas mentir ne pas tuer pour
guider pour guider nos actions quand on
ne sait pas du tout ce qui va marcher ou
pas même quand on pense à voir mais mais
mais se met sur le fond est là dessus je
suis je suis plutôt en accord avec le
fait que ce consensus là ce que ça te
paraît propre qu'elle profite et tu
mettrais c'est un truc assez fou j'ai
demandé mais ça paraît probable que
le grand public de ou grand public où
les politiciens savent et de questions
c'est beaucoup plus en conséquence la
liste parce que tu as tu as l'impression
que les gens sont son déontologue plutôt
conséquentialiste moi j'ai l'impression
que les gens se posent pas forcément la
question quoi mais je pense que la
plupart des gens en effet se pose pas la
question mais bon va si on comptera ce
tollé la communauté de la 3éme efficace
versus le grand public où les
politiciens exalte rice efficace on a
l'impression que j'allais sont beaucoup
plus conséquentialiste du coup est-ce
que ça ça ça te paraît possible que ça
se propage où je sais pas mais mais là
pour le coup j'ai j'ai moins
l'impression que ce soit quelque chose
de oued d'important à pousser quoi
georges ans si les gg ouais j'ai
l'impression qu'on peut arriver aux
mêmes conclusions par exemple à la
conclusion que c'est important d'aider
les autres par plein de différentes
théories moral je pense que si on est
déontologue par exemple donc ce qui est
ce qui importe c'est de respecter
certaines règles
on peut avoir certaines certaines normes
on peut avoir comme comme règle que
c'est
c'est vraiment important d'aider les
autres quoi enfin c'est que c'est que
c'est quelque chose que je sais que
c'est important de ces que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut qu'il faut toujours
qu'il peut toujours nous par exemple
dans le dans une théorie morale qui est
le l'éthique des vertus des caractères
jeu exactement comment on dit ça en
français mais on peut on peut dire que
que la générosité
le fait de nous mêmes la rationalité ça
peut être des vertus qui sont qui sont
importantes quoi donc tu peux en fait tu
peux partir et d'ailleurs il ya des
paper là dessus il ya des il ya des
articles sur est-ce qu'on peut arriver
aux conclusions de la crise mais
efficace en partant de systèmes moreau
qui sont complètement différents et il y
arrive quoi il arrive à rabat voilà on
pourrait on pouvait partir de donc ouais
je pense que je pense que c'est pas
forcément important de je pense que
c'est ce serait bien que les gens et
réfléchissent mais peut-être un peu plus
à quels sont leurs objectifs qu est-ce
que qu'est-ce que c'est qu'il considère
morales casquette voilà qu'est ce qui
est éthique pour eux mais après sur sur
persuadé les gens de passer un autre
système moral cision bien réfléchi et
qu'ils arrivent à des conclusions des
officiants très différentes
je ne sais pas mais ça me paraît pas
prioritaire mais je sais pas puisque
paris est ce que j'ai l'impression que
sur les riffs les listes en ciel en fête
la steppe us les à une approche
parisienne que une approche
conséquentialiste mobilisatrice efficace
le mouvement est très efficace donne
beaucoup plus d'importance au risque
essentiel que le grand public et j'ai
l'impression que c'est lié à une
perception au moins deux approches de du
futur et de l'incertitude et en
particulier avec une approche un peu
conséquent des passants quand même
quelque chose qui divergent à ce
niveau-là ça ce serait peut-être un
thème de conversation à avoir je pense
pas ça vraiment intéressant d'avoir ça
comme conversation avec olivier si tu
sais tu parles avec lui parce que lui la
ilaha illa il réfléchit pas mal il a
fait d un master de philo et c'est
vraiment d'aider des considérations
auxquelles il a énormément réfléchi
c'est vrai que j'ai pas penser comme ça
peut-être peut-être qu'il ya une
peut-être qu'il ya peut-être peut-être
que c'est à cause de ça que les légendes
et des intuitions divergentes mais
j'aimerais moi j'avais pas forcément
l'impression mais ça pourrait être
intéressant d'en discuter mais d'autres
avaient peut-être même une question plus
de psychologie quoi comment est ce qu'on
pense genre de problèmes et les
intuitions et donc pour parler voir
revenir un peu plus sur toi qui qui du
coup quelle est ta philosophie morale
s'il a réussi à offrir une wave je
trouve ça compliqué comme question parce
que j'ai toujours l'impression et j'ai
toujours l'impression qu'il me manque
plein plein d'infos et quand j'en
discute souvent j'arrive à adé à des
réflexions beaucoup plus médiatique sur
sur à quel point c'est possible de dakar
à quel point est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on
est ce qu'il ya vraiment une une
une vérité morale à quel point est-ce
qu'il faut prendre en compte
l'incertitude je suis beaucoup plus
intéressés par par des questions comme
ça où je sais même pas si j'ai une vraie
position là-dessus mais je suis
intéressé de djermaya question en
général je valorise beaucoup là la prise
en compte de l'incertitude sache pas je
pense que c'est vraiment très important
de se dire bah et d'ailleurs je dis je
dis moi comme si c'était un truc et qui
m'était très spécifique mais même dans
l'altruisme efficace william macaskill
qui est un des fondateurs de l'altruisme
efficace et qui avec un philosophe
d'oxford sa thèse c'était sur
l'incertitude moral et il a une grande
réflexion et c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est très important qui est
comment étant donné qu'à une petite
probabilité que ce soit le la
déontologie qu'ils soient vrais ou où
que ce soit donc que d'autres systèmes
moreau soit soit vrai ou alors qu'ils
aient aucun système moral qui qu'ils
soient vraies comment est ce qu'on prend
ça en compte dans nos dans nos
réflexions et comment est ce qu'on a on
a on peut quand même prendre des
décisions malgré toute cette incertitude
a plein plan de niveau 2 de meta essaoui
pareil je pourrais pas te dire
exactement la position que j'ai là
dessus mais c'est s'aider des
conversations je trouve vraiment
passionnante quoi c'est vraiment des
choses que j'adore discuter et je pense
que ouais je pense que c'est important
oui de prendre prendre ça en compte et
d'années donc été incertaine pas pour la
morale même si tu est incertaine
c'est si tu as le cadre de massana
casque il a priori tu mets des
probabilités sur sur différents
différentes chorales du coup tu peux
dire que ce que je te disais moi je suis
plutôt je suis plutôt d'accord avec avec
les idées du conseil socialiste je pense
que c'est ce et c'est ce qui est
vraiment important au fond c'est s'aider
conséquences de nos actions
je pense que ça ça des expériences de
pensée vraiment vraiment basique sûr
bon moi samassa moi ça marche pas mal
sur mon intuition c'est de dire par
exemple on est pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale on a and frank dans notre
grenier
on a une règle qui a il faut pas mentir
il ya des nazis qui arrive à notre porte
et qui nous demandent 'est-ce que anne
frank est cachée chez toi j'aurais du
mal à dire ah bah oui moi je ne peux pas
mentir donc oui effectivement anne frank
qui avaient caché chez moi je pense que
j'ai et puis voilà et puis je pense que
à la base c'est pas si important que ça
l'intention qu'on peut avoir ou les
règles de la halle de suivre des règles
très claires qu'on s'est fixés je pense
que c'est vraiment beaucoup plus
important au final qu'est ce qui se
passe et je pense que j'irais même plus
loin je pense que je pense que je je je
tends pas mal vers vers l'utilitarisme
c'est à dire je tends pas mal vers
l'idée que ce qui compte dans les gros
on regarde quoi comme conséquence on
regarde les conséquences sur le sur le
bien-être ou sur la souffrance des
individus ça ça moi je jeu ouais je suis
plutôt convaincu de cela je pense que
c'est compliqué je pense qu'il ya plein
de choses qui sont importantes je pense
que c'est important la vie je pense est
important la beauté je pense que c'est
important
l'amitié l'amour tout ça mais je pense
que c'est important de façon
instrumentale parce que ça rend les gens
plus heureux quand ces choses là
existent voilà et je pense que oui ça ça
cesse et j'ai des intuitions
relativement forte là dessus et sur
l'accueil charisme il ya plusieurs
variantes de l'utilitarisme que c'est
eux qui t'arrive additifs ou alors la
somme de tous les bonheurs qui compte au
total ou presque puisque la moyenne ou
est-ce que donc il ya il ya un milliard
il ya un podcast très intéressant de
d'une philosophe d'oxford qui s'appelle
red wings où elle explique que de toute
façon il faut toujours choisir son
poison que on a en a il ya des problèmes
il ya vraiment des problèmes
fondamentaux avec toutes les théories
moral des trucs où il ya un moment ça
clashe complètement avec nos intuitions
et puis on se dit
ben là ça arrive un truc avec lequel je
suis pas d'accord et puis à un moment si
vraiment on veut une théorie morale
unifiée et cohérente
eh bien il faut choisir choisir laquelle
avec laquelle on est le moins
inconfortable
et voilà moi je pensais pas obligatoire
mais pas forcément obligatoire de
choisir un truc de se dire ah bah oui ok
je suis vraiment pas d'accord avec cette
conclusion là mais quand même je veux
absolument un framework un cadre moral
unifiée et cohérente donc donc je vais
me pencher vers ça je pense que c'est
passé pas nécessaire mais ceci étant dit
s'il faut s'il fallait choisir quelque
chose moi je pense que je pense que je
priorise pas mal la réduction de la
souffrance jeu
je pense que c'est important de c'est
peut être plus important si on doit
choisir par exemple entre eux voilà il
ya quelqu'un qui est qui est heureux
qu'ils aient bien qu'à une vie sympa
mais il pourrait être encore plus
heureux par exemple il pourrait on
pourrait pour lui offrir un jet pilot je
ne sais pas ce qui se passe qu'est ce
que ça qui est le leur rendra heureux
c'est cette personne n'essaie de
personnes imaginaire mais mais mais on
pourrait imaginer des pensées des
ressources pour que cette personne là
soit encore plus heureuse et de l'autre
côté on pourrait imaginer quelqu'un qui
est un peu malheureux enfin bouquet ou
non quelqu'un qui est vraiment très
malheureux qui est qui et qui souffre
d'énormes souffrances et laon le
rendrait un petit peu moins malheureux
donc on aurait l'équivalent si on a une
espèce d'échelle de juste une courbe
d'utilité et baron le on dépenserait des
ressources pour cette personne là soit
soit un peu moins malheureuse ça me
paraît beaucoup plus important de me
focaliser là-dessus sûr sûr sûr sûr sûr
les gens qui souffrent sur les individus
qui souffre plutôt que sur améliorer un
tout petit peu ou même beaucoup le
bonheur de gens qui sont déjà heureux
donc voilà donc je priorise jeu puis
appeler plusieurs systèmes moreau qui
peuvent à peu prendre ça en compte que
j'aurais du mal à définir est ici très
bien mais les des systèmes qui s'appelle
pas pour ceux qui s'intéressent à sa
haine système s'appelle lexsi qualité
il ya 34 ans coulisses myard ya des
questions de priorité priori charisme je
sais pas qu on appelle ça mes deux
priorités risme de la souffrance
il ya pas mal de de wade de cadres
moreau qui qui qui permettent de
répondre un peu à cette intuition que
c'est plus important la souffrance que
le que le bien est ok et si on donc pas
parler un peu de métal tik tok et est ce
que tu vois des façons de de mieux
penser les différentes morale ou de
choisir une morale donc donc ta question
ce serait ce serait quoi exactement ce
serait cesser voix question un côté
réflexion autour de la médiatique qu'est
ce comment est ce qu'il faudrait penser
différente éthique web est là la météo
c'est aussi peut-être parce que j ai pas
gg pas assez assez réfléchi ou quoi mais
là dessus moi je suis plutôt je suis
plutôt convaincu par parce que ce que
dit macaskill de deux mètres des
probabilités à différents systèmes
moreau et puis de de prendre des
décisions voilà donc un niveau de
métallo d'éthique de deux mètres des
probabilités à différents systèmes et
puis après de prendre de prendre des
décisions en fonction de ce nouveau
concept nouvelle ce nouveau cadre
éthique mais bon ça ça pose pas mal de
problèmes ça pose pas mal de problèmes
genre si si on met une importance
infinie si un système moral mais une
importance infinie sur quelque chose sur
par exemple une norme qu'il faut pas
violer et si on viole cette norme c'est
infiniment mal c'est le plus mal qu'on
peut c'est très difficile à près de 2 de
pouvoir avoir un système qui marche bien
un truc un peu mathématisée jolie avec
avec des probabilités donc donc ça ne
marche pas ça marche pas parfaitement
mais tout ça enfin je me sens vraiment
je trouve ça je trouve ça passionnant
rend donc je pense que c'est mais pour
pour prendre des vraies décisions
je pense que souvent c'est pas c'est pas
pertinent d'aller aussi loin je pense
qu'on peut avoir des pansements ce que
c'est vraiment intéressant
on soit de se poser ces questions-là et
qu'après pour une fois qu'on y
réfléchisse un peu qu'on arrive à plein
de problèmes qu'on voit que quelle que
soit la façon dont on y réfléchit on
arrive à un truc insoluble et qui marche
pas très bien et qui je pense que c'est
c'est chouette de c'est important de
prendre des décisions
malgré sa 2e bon ben voilà il ya je suis
pas d'accord avec tout c'est pas
exactement mon cadre moral tout ne
marche pas je sais bien que ça peut pas
exactement marché mais ça me pointe vers
la direction de ce qui est important
pour moi et voilà c'est ce que ce n'état
pas dépasser les les choses que je veux
vraiment avoir en tête pour prendre des
décisions mais c'est intéressant d'avoir
des princes il ya une action qu'on peut
prendre et qui est valable sur toutes
les philosophies morale la cbc ça est
exactement pas mal causé exactement s'il
essaie d'identifier au moins ces cases
laisse un peu ça c'est intéressant
d'avoir réfléchi à différentes
perspectives morale pour essayer de
comprendre enfin de trouver celle qui
marche pour tout l'été sauf il y aura le
cas les plus prédominante ce que je vois
la polarisation idéologique je pas si
c'est un sujet qui seront discutés par
oui pas mal parce que la veille après 18
mois qu'il ya pas mal de polarisation
idéologique qui al'air d'augmenter est
ce qu'il ya des réflexions autour de soi
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
ouais ouais pas mal donc l'ajustement au
dernier y est globale il y avait une
présentation assurent les les conflits
entre grandes puissances et il était
aussi il y avait des réflexions donc
balader à des conférenciers j mais aussi
sur l'eau sur le blog l'altruisme
efficace et a pas mal d'endroits sur
quelles sont les conséquences de de
cesser polarisation exacerbée qu'est ce
qui peut être fait je pense que c'est
cdc des questions qui intéressent
beaucoup de gens je pense que la réponse
c'est souvent
que con qu'il ya des experts qui
travaillent là dessus et qui n'a pas
forcément énormément qu'on peut ajouter
avec avec ce mouvement-là de l'altruisme
efficace à à moins d'avoir simplement
des gens peut être un peu plus rationnel
et un peu plus un peu plus altruiste qui
travaillent dans certains grands
gouvernements mais il n'y a pas
forcément une réflexion qu'on peut qu'on
peut apporter qui qu'ils soient plus
fiables que celles des experts en
géopolitique et en relations
internationales actuelles il ya
peut-être ouais c'est ça il ya peut-être
des façons de penser des réflexes
épistémique tous à avoir et puis aussi
une option peut se dire que 1 des soucis
qui qu'il y a dans la façon dont le
monde est gouverné
aujourd'hui c'est que il ya des intérêts
qui entrent en conflit les les gens
élisent les citoyens élisent des
gouvernements pour les représenter eux
donc par exemple au niveau national il
pas pour représenter quelqu'un d'autre
donc si si on est aux états unis et
qu'on élit un président pour pour nous
représenter et pour représenter nos
intérêts ce président là il a hélas d
incitation très forte à représenter les
intérêts des états unis même si sa nuit
très fortement aux intérêts d'autres
pays du monde
d'autres d'autres d'autres peuples
d'autres qu'ils soient qui ont pas
pourront pas voter pour lui ça les
problèmes de gouvernance pour le coup de
oued de comment est ce qu'on peut
améliorer soient les systèmes électoraux
soient les prises de décisions mondiales
pour donner des incitations à des
acteurs qu'ils soient qu'ils soient plus
favorables à l'ensemble de l'humanité
ça c'est des considérations qui sont pas
mal abordé
il ya eu un centre récemment un centre
pour la science des élections qui c'est
qui s'est fondée aux états unis et je
crois et qui a été financé en grande
partie par l'open philanthropie project
qui est efficace qu'il ya une réflexion
sur les systèmes de gouvernance qui
peuvent qui peuvent garantir des
haute comme un peu un peu moins mauvais
mais surtout ce qui est relations
internationales à proprement parler
ouais il ya quand même énormément de
réflexion déjà les des gouvernements
sont pleins de gens très intelligents
qui réfléchissent à la diplomatie et là
dessus ouais là dessus je pense qu'elle
la conclusion pour le moment mais la
confusion pour le moment c'est qu'on n'a
pas forcément grand chose de plus à
apporter et sur l'épaule et polarisation
au sein d'un pays donc le fait que les
cantons ne compte pas de doux légalisme
politique ou quoi ou que les gens les
gens sont plus opposés à au camp adverse
qui qu'ils étaient acquises étaient
auparavant
ça ça ça intéresse beaucoup de gens mais
les solutions les solutions qui sont
donnés j'ai jamais vu des choses qui
étaient particulièrement original dans
la trousse médicale afin d'aider des
choses que je n'ai pas vu mentionné
ailleurs dans des dans des journaux ou
par des par des experts en géopolitique
quoi moi il me semble que pour pareil
pour le point de la polarisation c'est
ultra important aujourd'hui de de faire
attention plus aux réseaux sociaux et de
recommandations
du coup ça reviendrait je pense que
c'est ça c'est vraiment urgent d'en
passer par là et de faire en sorte que
la recommandation soit parce
qu'aujourd'hui vont ça maximise
notamment pas mal là là là la tension ou
la rétention le fait que les gens
cliquent et sa tendance à favoriser des
sujets et de fontenay qui énerve
l'indignation et ainsi de suite
et du coup il semble que c'est urgent de
changer la fonction de l'actif de saisir
pour établir les preuves de polarisation
est ce que le sujet des les des
inégalités aussi abordé par l'efficace
l'augmentation des inégalités notamment
au sein des pays développés
oui mais alors c'est surtout alors moi
ce que j'ai vu c'est souvent s'est
souvent faite de on y réfléchit souvent
de manière instrumentale c'est souvent
voilà qu'est ce que est ce que les
inégalités rendre les gens malheureux
déjà est ce que le fait que voilà qu'on
est con on est con et moins - pas juste
pas riche dans l'absolu mais moins
riches quelqu'un d'autre est-ce que ça
c'est important et empiriquement c'est
plutôt oui la réponse lazer c'est
vraiment étonnant à quel point la
richesse relative joue plus dans la
satisfaction reporter des gens que la
richesse absolue
voici quelque chose qui me rend qui me
rend vraiment pessimiste d'ailleurs
c'est quelque chose qui me rend vraiment
vraiment triste le fait qu' on peut on
peut essayer d'augmenter par exemple
toute la la la la la richesse de chaque
habitant d'un pays où même au même du
monde et que finalement c'est tout le
monde augmente pareil ou si tout le
monde sait s'il continue à y avoir des
des différences et l'aîné différence il
ya souvent et souvent même des
différences minimes et l'élève le fait
que les gens fonctionnent plus sûrs
d'eux avait avec une avec une perception
comparative ça me fait assez peur mais
je sais pas exactement comment comment
régler ce souci là
je sais par exemple que c'est une
considération qui est prise en compte
donc là je reviens sur les seuls pays en
développement plutôt que les pays
développés mais c'est l'association
l'organisation guide dans votre lit qui
fait des des dons de d'une année de
salaire aux familles les plus pauvres du
monde qui repère les familles les plus
pauvres du monde et après leur donne
directement en fait de l'argent plutôt
que de leur donner des médicaments ou
accès à l'école ou autre oui elle a
comme quand il s'est rendu compte de ça
que le fait que c'est c'est qu'en
faisant un don à une famille est bien là
la famille d'à côté et le bonheur de la
famille bien-être a reporté de la
famille d'à côté diminuait plus que le
bien-être reporter des délais de la
famille à quel laquelle on m'avait il
dit à quand il s'est rendu compte de ça
elle a changé son système de répartition
des ressources maintenant elle elle
donne à des villages entiers
elles donnent plutôt que de donner à idg
de choisir une famille et bien elle va
choisir un village elle va donner à tous
le veinage newey c'est fou comme
monsieur et sur les sur les
problématiques de pays développés enfin
je sais pas si la déception fait
toujours sans ça je parle de développer
en développement ça fait schématique
mais ouais il ya pas mal de réflexion
sur way sur le fait que que par exemple
le lait le bien-être augmente enfin que
c'est que c'est un petit peu compliqué
que que dans les trousses mais efficace
à yahia on se concentre pas mal sur les
gens les plus riches du monde pour les
plus riches ou les plus éduqués ou avec
les plus de ressources du monde pour
pour leur demander de pour leur demander
en tout cas pour qu'ils travaillent sûr
sûr sûr sûr sûr des problèmes du monde
donc on se concentre sur sur cette
partie de la population et on se
concentre aussi sur les gens qui sont le
plus malheureux ou le plus pauvre où le
plus qui souffrent le plus au monde ce
qui ce qui paraît ce qui paraît logique
si on pense que c'est parce que c'est
important de réduire la souffrance et
est par contre il ya toute une toute une
énorme partie de la population où il
n'ya pas toujours on n'a pas toujours
quelque chose à leur dire quoi
ils sont pas priorisées dans les
interventions typiquement typiquement
recommandé parle pas différente
d'organisation d'un trust l'efficace et
c'est pas les premières cibles quand
quand on cherche des gens à qui faire du
conseil de carrière ou faire du conseil
en philanthropie ou je ne sais quoi et
ça c'est une question pareille qui
revient pas mal dans nos mouvements qui
aimait à temps est ce que est ce que est
ce que le fait qui est dédé et quand
même d'éviter grossissante même même au
sein des pays
est-ce que c'est pas un souci que
quelques et toute une partie de la
population
cd je sais pas s'il ya des très bonnes
réponses à l'heure actuelle mais c'est
des préoccupations ouais bah du coup
voilà le dernier problème que je
soulevais ces points d des ressources
naturelles est ce que c'est vrai est-ce
qu'elle très efficace y intéresser parce
que vous voyez ça qu'on a un problème
alors je sais pas trop ce que c'est la
position de où le consensus au sein de
la troupe efficace sur des ressources
naturelles je sais que altruisme
efficace français ya pas mal de gens qui
s'intéressent pour le mot aux questions
de collapse au logis tous acquis qui se
posent des questions là-dessus avec pas
mal david divers il ya eu des critiques
ou des critiques et des contres
critiques certains arguments des
collabos log
ouais je sais pas ce que c'est ma
position personnelle là dessus et j'ai
pas vu grand chose sur ouais j'ai pas vu
en tout cas récemment j'ai pas vu grand
chose sur sur les problématiques liées
aux ressources naturelles dans wells
assure sur le forum de la truite mais
efficace internationale mais oui
j'aurais peut-être que je regarde un peu
mieux bon ben ça clôt appelé les
questions je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'autre à ajouter par rapport à ça
doit venir de derrière question la balle
avant dernière question du coup c'est à
quel message clé que tu aimerais que les
auditeurs obtienne de ce fait qui est
web à j'ai l'impression que
intuitivement joreige aurait insisté
plus sur l'important c'est de bien
réfléchir
quid de la réflexion d'avoir des bottes
des bonnes bonnes normes de penser et de
débats et puis de réfléchir avant d'agir
georges au jour et j'en ai dit que
c'était mon message important
sauf que j'ai l'impression que avec un
public comme comme tous les étés auditop
des viewers ça c'est vraiment un message
que que tu fais passer tout le temps
quoi c'est vraiment c'est vraiment ton
message aussi et c'est pas grave de le
répéter c'est pas grave de le répéter
mais je pense que pour pour un public
qui est vraiment être déjà je sais pas
si celle ci c'est le cas mais qui est
déjà en tout cas en partie convaincu que
c'est important de bien penser et de
réfléchir de pas ne pas agir à
l'intuition
je pense que quelque chose d'important
que je voudrais que les gens retirent de
sas et c'est aussi important d'agir quoi
qu'on a forcément pas mal d'incertitudes
surtout à tous les niveaux empiriquement
normativement nelson sa métaphysique et
que et que malgré ça je veux dire
l'absence d'action le fait de ne pas
agir c'est une décision en soi et donc
c'est ça empêche pas en fait en fait le
fait de ne pas prendre de décision c'est
pas c'est pas une solution à cette
incertitude c'est juste une décision
qu'on prend ça va ça va orienter avère
en had come plutôt plutôt qu'un autre et
que donc c'est quand même important un
moment de se lancer de traduire notre
notre réflexion en action et puis de
vote les deux s'alimente quoique en
agissant on se rend compte aussi de
certaines choses auxquelles on n'avait
pas pensé donc de mieux réfléchir mais
voilà d'un moment allez-y si vous avez
des c'est vous avez des ddd des
ressources que vous pouvez louer à des à
des choses qui sont qui sont importantes
des idées de projets je ne sais quoi
une fois que vous avez bien réfléchi
confronter ses idées à celles d'autres
gens échanger pendant pendant un moment
il faut faut y aller quoi c'est comme
les jags acquis et j'aime bien scellier
qui est hilarant que être rationnel
c'est aussi prendre conscience
de no limit hold'em cognitives et on
peut plus avancer avec noémie cognitif
c'est qu'il faut agir dans l'incertitude
c'est totalement justifié et ça et ça
peut être juste pour faire un message un
peu plus concret nous on voudrait bien
avec avec un truisme efficace france
offrir un cadre pour que les gens
puissent non seulement réfléchir mais
aussi agir et se coordonner
donc ça c'est vraiment aussi un message
que je peux avoir qui est vénéré quoi
venez venez réfléchir avec d'autres gens
restez pas dans votre coin avec vos
réflexions il ya pas mal qui peut être
gagné a échangé avec avec d'autres
personnes as well as mettre en en
challenge et sur les opinions vous
pouvez avoir quelqu'un que vous voilà
c'est important et puis les gens notre
édification tout ce que j'ai rencontrés
c'est très souvent très très très sympa
voilà en plus au moins y aura un petit
récente de la bière est est ce que tu
vas faire du coup deux recommandations
de vidéos podcasts ou livres ou de
personnes à suivre
bon donc je vais pas j'ai pas mentionné
julien bellec et les vidéos pour les
gens qui s'intéressent vraiment si elle
si on reste sur la thématique un peu
altruisme efficace qui occupe quand même
mon monde intérêt principal mais pour
les gens qui s'intéressent beaucoup à
ces questions là est qui et qui sont
anglophones aussi ça c'est c'est surtout
des ressources qui sont en anglais mais
je recommande vraiment le forum de la
truite mais efficace donc iphone homme
qui il ya vraiment des échanges super
intéressant quoi des gens qui proposent
des idées
super nouvelle qui se répondent les uns
les autres plein de commentaires pleins
de deux poètes d'argumentation sur sur
différents points soit très technique
soit philosophique soit hyper concret
ç'a vraiment vraiment je leur demande
beaucoup et puis et puis aussi les
clients dans la vie dans le même genre
le forum rationaliste donc la seconde
qui paraît il ya plein de postes super
intéressant d pour pour signifier à tout
ce qui est rationalité tout ça je pense
que c'est top
et puis pour aller plus loin aussi voilà
ouais effet sinon quand tu parlais de
polarisation ça m'avait fait penser à
une ressource que moi j'aime bien qui
est encore en anglais donc j'ai
peut-être fait pas je sais pas j'ai pas
de super idée d'une ressource en
français mais mais je peux y réfléchir
mais mais il ya une newsletter super à
laquelle je suis abonné qui s'appelle
flipside et et paris xiii américano
centré c'est surtout pour pour les
américains mais je me disais s'il y
avait la même chose en français ce
serait top je rêve que quelqu'un fasse
la même chose en français qui étaient
des deux projets ouais mais peut-être
que ça existe et que je connais pas mais
en tout cas c'est newsletter qui qui
donne un peu de façon un peu schématique
mais qui donne la perspective de la
gauche la perspective de la droite sur
une sur une thématique donnée qui est
souvent des thématiques sont souvent des
thématiques donc propre propre aux états
unis qui ont a résumé qu'il essaye
d'être le plus neutre possible en haut
et puis qui donne les meilleurs
arguments en fait des journaux de gauche
des journaux de droite des journalistes
de gauche et de droite sur sur un sujet
et c'est vraiment moi je trouve ça fou
parce que à chaque fois je je je pars
peut-être avec un peu de un à un a
priori sur sur ce que sur ce que je
pense de telle ou telle thématique est
en fait en lisant le point de vue
intelligente le lait les meilleurs
arguments de l'autre côté je me dis oui
c'est vrai je vais pas considérer sa
bomba change pas complètement d'avis
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que là il
ya aussi ça comme argument et ccc ccc
super con je connais pas de trucs en
version française de ce serait une bonne
idée de
sur votre cas merci beaucoup
laura pour avoir participé à cet épisode
de te probablement pour les auditeurs
penser à liker commenté et tout ça et
puis je vous dis à bientôt pour une
prochaine fois